accepter
de répondre favorablement à la à la
sollicitation même même si par ailleurs
c'est un peu une obligation cont tenu de
nos textes mais voilà c'est quand même
bien de
remercier normal
euh donc je m'adresse à mes à mes
collègues ils peuvent se rapprocher
s'ils veulent être sur les sur les
images on est on est
filmé donc on poursuit les travaux de
notre commission d'enquête avec cet
après-midi l'audition Monsieur Olivier
bar euh délégué général du groupement
des industriels français de l'énergie
nucléaire le
gifen bonjour monsieur Monsieur Bernard
dorzuk président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire laasn monsieur Étienne dutille
directeur de la division production
nucléaire à la direction production
nucléaire et thermique d'électricité de
France voilà vous êtes par ailleurs
accompagné par Monsieur letiec pour pour
Monsieur duteille et
Monsieur très bien alors je me dois de
de vous faire prêter serment donc avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle comme faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévus aux articles 434- 13-1
ET-1 du code pénal et je vous invite à
prêter serement de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité en levant la main
droite et en disant je le jure donc au
trois personnes invitées
merci quelques mots de présentation de
la commission elle a été constitué le 18
janvier
dernier sur la sur le thème de la
production la consommation et le prix de
l'électricité aux horizons 2035 et
2050 les travaux sont centrés sur le
présent et l'avenir du système
électrique est-il en capacité de faire
face à la demande d'offrir au
particulier à nos entreprises une
électricité à un prix raisonnable quels
sont ces perspective de de développement
donc l'objet de la Table Ronde
d'aujourd'hui est important essentiel
parce qu'il nous faut apprécier la
situation actuelle de notre parc
nucléaire après les nombreuses
difficultés qu'il a qu'il a pu connaître
quelle est la capacité de production de
ce parc à court et moyen terme quelle
perspective en terme de maintenance et
de prolongation des réacteurs comment
les responsables se
prémissent-ils de la survenue de
nouvelles difficultés en la matière en
clair comment éviter l'arrêt de nombreux
réacteurs pour des raisons de
maintenance où en est le le programme de
de grand carénage voilà quelques thèmes
euh sur lesquels notre rapporteur va va
va vous interroger ainsi que nos nos
collègues donc je on vous propose de
dérouler cette audition en quatre temps
euh vous présenterai donc successivement
votre travail et vos réflexions en 10
minutes maximum de présentation limit
minaire je pense que ça vous a été dit
certainement euh ça sera suivi d'un d'un
temps de de questionsréponse en
particulier de avec notre rapporteur
Vincent de à qui je vais céder la parole
puis par les autres membres de la de la
Commission et vous pourrez
éventuellement revenir sur les les
propos des uns et des autres nous
pourrons terminer par une dernière
batterie de de questionsréponsse
euh voilà avant de passer la parole à à
à monsieur duteille qui qui qui
débutera je laisse la parole à Monsieur
le le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
messieurs merci merci de votre
présence comme l'a dit monsieur le
Président elle est obligatoire mais bon
en même temps on est content de vous
avoir en face de nous pour nous éclairer
un peu alors c'est vrai que moi je suis
à l'origine de la création de cette
commission d'enquête qui est
complémentaire de celle qui a été
réalisée à l'Assemblée nationale qui
portait plus sur le passé et sur la
politique énergétique en général de de
la France et là on a voulu se concentrer
sur l'électricité
euh
l'électricité présente et puis future
bien sûr les perspective à la fois de
consommation de production et de prix
euh
donc avec l'électrification de nos
usages euh voilà on a on a pu déjà faire
le point un peu sur l'écosystème en
général électrique on a fait euh on a
fait une première audition sur les
perspectives de consommation qui sont
pas si évidentes que cela déterminé
puisque on a une baisse de la
consommation sur les 10 dernières années
que bah voilà on prévoit une
augmentation forte dans les prochaines
années quand est-ce que ça va démarrer
réellement et puis et puis là
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur donc sur
la production avec vous sur la
production en partant du nucléaire
existant sachant qu'on aura aussi des
auditions sur le le nucléaire du futur
et les perspectives qu'on peut avoir à
la fois de PR de de de SMR et
autres autres nucléaires de 4e
génération donc là
euh notre propos aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt de parler pour les collègues qui
sont présents donc de du parc nucléaire
actuel de son vieillissement de son état
et ses
perspectives voilà on a on a une baisse
avec la fermeture de pas mal de
réacteurs on a une baisse de la
production importante est-ce que on a
des perspectives aussi de revenir vers
des des productions qui étaient à 400
tawh ou est-ce qu'on va
rester dans les 300 320 voilà mais je
vous laisse comme l'a dit le président
peut-être nous livrer un propos
liminaire qui nous permettra de rebondir
sur un certain nombre de
questions Monsieur duteille Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE merci bonjour madame la sénatrice
bonjour messieurs les sénateurs bonjour
mesames et
messieurs je voudrais d'abord vous dire
que le le parc nucléaire est
actuellement dans une phase nouvelle
inédite de de son histoire industrielle
avec actuellement un volume d'activité
sur nos centrales sur nos réacteur qui
est extrêmement soutenu et qui est bien
plus important que ce que nous avions
connu dans le passé euh à titre
d'exemple les les 4è visites décennal
des réacteurs de 900 MW qui sont
actuellement en cours de réalisation
représente un volume d'activité qui est
six fois supérieur à celui des
précédents examens périodiqu
c'est-à-dire des examens périodiques des
30 ans donc vous voyez une augmentation
très importante le nombre d'heures
travaillé dans la partie nucléaire de
l'installation est passé aux alentours
de vers 2014 de 6 millions d'heures 6,3
exactement à plus de 7 millions en
2022 tout tout ceci s'explique par le
plusieurs facteurs le le premier c'est
que nous menons des travaux
d'amélioration de la sûreté qui visent à
porter les réacteurs actuels qui sont ce
qu'on appelle des réacteurs de 2e
génération construits dans les années
80-90 au niveau de sûreté de par leur
design des réacteurs de 3e génération
c'est-à-dire les PR parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a coexistence finalement de ces
deux générations de réacteurs sur notre
parc et euh l'objectif est de tous les
amener aussi proche que possible du
meilleur niveau et puis il y a d'autres
aspects qui sont liés à la maintenance
au vieillissement de notre installation
nous avons des composants qui arrivent
en fin de vie technique alors la fin de
vie d'un composant peut être inférieur à
la fin de vie visée pour l'installation
elle-même et donc il faut procéder à des
remplacements je peux citer un exemple
les transformateurs par exemple
transformateurs de grande puissance ont
des isolants qui vieillissent avec le
temps et la durée de vie d'un
transformateur est aux alentours de 2025
ans la durée de vie d'une centrale n'est
évidemment pas de 20 25 ans donc il faut
les remplacer de proche en proche nous
sommes actuellement dans une période où
nous avons à remplacer un certain nombre
de ces gros composants c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la maintenance exceptionnelle
donc vous voyez un contexte d'activité
très soutenu des modifications visantes
à améliorer le le le design de
l'installation d'une part de la
maintenance exceptionnelle plus
importante que auparavant d'autres part
et puis le niveau d'exigence que l'on
applique aujourd'hui pour faire
fonctionner nos réacteurs a
augmenté c'est pas une particularité du
nucléaire je pense qu'il y a aucune
industrie sur lequel le le niveau
d'exigence progressivement n'augmente
pas et donc aujourd'hui on réalise plus
de contrôle on a plus de critères à
vérifier afant avant de de redémarrer un
réacteur donc notre activité est devenue
plus complexe et tout
ceci s'est produit à un moment où
objectif efftivement nous avons eu une
perte d'expérience de nos de nos
salariés une perte d'expérience aussi
des salariés des entreprise partenaires
tout simplement parce que nous avons eu
un un très fort taux de renouvellement
et même si nous avons anticipé ce
renouvellement qui était lié au départ à
la retraite des gens qui ont démarré le
parc nucléaire bien même si nous avons
anticipé objectivement quand vous
remplacez quelqu'un qui a 10 ou 20 ans
d'expérience sur des arrêts de réacteur
par quelqu'un qui n'en a que deux ou
trois bah vous avez tout de même une
perte expérience qui se fait
sentir pour ces raisons lorsque j'ai été
nommé directeur de la division
production nucléaire j'ai voulu lancer
un programme de transformation centré
exclusivement sur l'amélioration de la
maîtrise des arrêt de réacteur alors
c'est un un point qui peut paraître un
peu surprenant mais la performance
industrielle la performance de
production d'un du parc nucléaire dépend
essentiellement de la façon dont on
maîtrise les périodes d'arrêt en fait
vous maîtrisez la production en
maîtrisant la période d'arrêt puisque
quand un réacteur est redémarré et bien
ma fois si on en prend soin il
fonctionne plutôt bien on a une un taux
de de de fiabilité de comment dire de de
de
disponibilité durant les périodes où les
réacteurs sont couplés qui qui est de 97
98 % donc l'essentiel c'est de maîtriser
ces périodes d'arrêt durant lesqueles je
c'est mon propos précédent nous
réalisons de plus en plus d'activités et
les les la maîtrise de ces arrêts de
réacteur est une activité qui nécessite
de
l'expérience ce sont des métiers qui si
je vais le dire un petit peu
trivialement ne s'apprennent pas à
l'école donc ce programme qui a été
lancé en 2019 s'appelle start 2025 start
voyons voulant dire soyons tous acteurs
de la réussite des arrêts tranches le le
sens est bien celui-ci c'estàdire que
sur un site de production il n'y a
personne qui peut ou prou ne contribue
pas à la maîtrise de de ces périodes de
ces périodes d'arrêt je je vais pas être
trop long sur la description de de de
Start 2025 mais je voudrais simplement
le le décrire en quatre grands points le
premier consiste à adapter
l'organisation des sites euh y compris
sur le dimensionnement des équipes à
leur programme industriel chaque arrêt
de de réacteur est un un petit projet
euh qui est confié à une équipe dédiée
qui commence à à travailler 18 mois 1 an
avant la période d'arrêt elle-même et il
est essentiel sur un site d'avoir le bon
nombre d'équipes qui peuvent travailler
en parallèle de manière à ce que lorsque
l'arrêt se réalise il soit correctement
préparé sur un site où vous avez quatre
réacteurs par exemple vous avez en
permanence trois équipes d'arrêt qui
sont en train de travailler soit sur un
arrêt en cours soit sur des arrêt en
phase de préparation donc l'adaptation
le avoir un nombre d'équipes
parfaitement qual ibré par rapport à
notre programme industriel est un point
extrêmement
important sur un un site avec quatre
réacteurs par exemple il nécessa d'avoir
deux équipes d'arrêt nous avons
également dans Star 2025 entamé la
création d'équipes volantes qui peuvent
aller d'un site à l'autre pour pouvoir
les renforcer en cas de pic de charge
deuxième point c'est travailler sur les
compétences j'ai souligné l'importance
des compéten et de l'expérience des gens
donc ça veut dire que nous devons avoir
des parcours professionnels qui
favorisent le temps long avec des gens
plus expérimentés nous travaillons
également sur l'entraînement des équipes
juste avant de réaliser l'opération nous
avons entamé un programme de
réinternalisation d'activités de
maintenance de manière à nous renforcer
en compétence sur des domaines où les
activités étaient confié à des
partenaires industriels et puis pour ce
qui est de nos partenaires industriels
nous faisons appel progressivement à
plus d'équipes de spécialistes plutôt
qu'à des généralistes spécialistes qui
connaissent les spécificités euh
vraiment de détail de nos matériels
troisème point c'est gagner en
efficacité avec ce qu'on appelle le
temps métal c'est-à-dire le temps utile
sur le terrain là ce sont des recettes
industrielles qui n'ont rien de
particulier au nucléaire nous
travaillons aussi sur la standardisation
de nos procédures nous avons la chance
de disposer de de réacteurs qui sont
tous identiques et donc nous nous avons
conçu des fonds documentaires qui
s'appliquent partout ce qui permet de
gagner beaucoup de temps vous utilisez
partout le même le même fond
documentaire et et nous
avons nous utilisons davantage les
effets de cette standardisation de not
documentation et nous visons une
réduction par deux par exemple du temps
de préparation de nos arrêts de réacteur
et puis nous industrialisons également
les activités de maintenance elle-même
de manière à les répéter à l'identique
sur tous nos réacteurs alors
qu'auparavant nous faisions un petit peu
plus de haute couture si je puis dire et
puis 4è point c'est faire évoluer les
modes de ménagement du parc NUC CLIRE
avec un un système de management plus
responsabilisant euh plus décentralisé
et et moins processé qui vise à donner
plus de sens au travail l'objectif étant
d'avoir des équipes engagées compétentes
en nombre suffisant qui travaillent
efficacement à la réussite de nos arrêts
tranche
euh star 2025 se traite des des des des
problème de fond de de maîtrise des des
arrêts de réacteurs et commence à
produire des résultats j'ajoute qu'il a
été construit le plus possible en mode
participatif avec les gens sur le
terrain et aujourd'hui nous avons des
sites qui commencent à renouer avec de
bonnes performances industrielles sur
les les arrêts de de réacteur euh et en
particulier en 2023 nous avons quelques
sites si vous voulez je pourrais les les
donner plus de détails par la suite qui
ont réussi des performances qui
n'avaient pas atteint depuis 10 ans sur
leurs arrêts de réacteur alors notre
obti faut toujours rester extrêmement
humble donc nous sommes très loin euh du
de du du bout du chemin si je puis dire
mais le goût de la réussite au sein des
équipes le goût de la réussite des
arrêts de tranche est en train de
revenir le tout ne se faisant pas au
détriment de la sûreté puisque
l'amélioration de la performance
industrielle c'est faite de paire avec
une amélioration de performances de
sûreté donc c'est bien la production et
la sûreté ainsi que la sécurité qui sont
visés il s'agit d'une maîtrise
industrielle
globale nos perspectives de production
sont donc à la hausse dans ce contexte
avec une charge industrielle qui demeure
très élevée donc nous avons produit
320,4 TWh en 2023 ce qui est
significativement plus qu'en 2022
laquelle était une année tout à fait
atypique nous visons une fourchette de
production de 315 à 335 terw en 2024
puis 335 à 365 en 2025 et 2026 vous avez
noté qu'il y a un palier entre 2025 et
2026 nous sommes assez prudents sur
l'année 2026 parce que en 2026 nous
allons débutter les 4è visites
décennales des réacteurs de 1300 MW
génération d'après les 900 MW donc nous
allons débuter euh ces ces 4e visite
décenale nous les préparons dès à
présent hein bien sûr et et et depuis
déjà quelques temps
euh nous sommes confiants mais ça sera
euh des têtes de série donc il faut être
un petit peu prudent sur la durée de ces
4e visite décennal c'est pour cela que
nous avons un palier de production en
2000 en 2026 notre objectif ensuite
c'est celui que nous a assigné lucrémont
est d'aller vers 400 terw avec la mise
en service de flamament ville 3 avec des
augmentations de puissance le cas
échéant sur les réacteur de 900 MW et de
1300 MW avec un allongement des
campagnes de production c'est-à-dire de
la période qui sépare deux arrêts de
réacteurs sur les réacteurs de 900 MW et
puis avec les effets de Start 2025 qui
de plus en plus doivent se faire sentir
à cela s'ajoute une perspective nouvelle
pour nous qui est celle de la durée de
fonctionnement je vous en
prie les effets sur la production c'est
que si vous arrivez à mieux maîtriser
vos périodes d'arrêt de réacteur et bien
vous avez des périodes de production qui
sont plus longues en fait le point
essentiel c'est vraiment de maîtriser la
durée de ces arrêts parce que une fois
que le réacteur est recouplé au réseau
en règle générale il fonctionne bien
sans interruption par contre ce qui est
clé pour augmenter la la production
c'est de maîtriser la durée
d'arrêt donc le ce qui est nouveau pour
nous c'est euh ce sont les perspectives
de de durée de fonctionnement euh alors
durée de fonctionnement qui chez nous
vous savez régie par est rythmé plutôt
par des visites décennales tous les 10
ans nous devons obtenir auprès
d'autorité de sûreté nucléaire euh une
une autorisation euh pour simplifier de
fonctionner 10 ans de plus il y a des
conditions à remplir c'est pour ça que
nous faisons des travaux de de de
modification euh néanmoins nous
projetons vers une perspective de
fonctionnement à 60 ans et nous avons
même ouvert un euh sujet et des
discussions avec l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire on avec l'IRSN ont débuté sur
l'après 60 ans donc il s'agit rien n'est
acquis bien sûr mais il s'agit de
travailler sur les conditions à réunir
pour permettre à nos réacteurs de
fonctionner 60 ans voire plus donc il
faut garantir évidemment la sûreté et
donc la la tenue des équipements qui
sont euh essentiel au bon fonctionnement
des réacteurs et en particulier aux
équipements qui ne sont pas remplaçables
parmi lesquels la cuve du réacteur cela
doit nous nous conduit à nous
réinterroger sur nos programmes de
maintenance exceptionnel puisque une
durée de fonctionnement plus importante
indique aussi plus de maintenance
exceptionnelle j'ai cité tout à l'heure
des transformateurs dont la durée de vie
industrielle est de l'ordre de 20 25 ans
si on fonctionne plus de 60 ans il faut
procéder à un deuxième remplacement dans
la vie du réacteur de de ces de ces
composants il s'agit aussi de travailler
sur la qualification des équipements
qualification aux conditions
accidentelles et puis travailler
également sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique don de multiples chantiers
qui sont ouverts pour investiguer cette
ce fonctionnement au-delà de de à 60 ans
ou plus sur un fond qui est celui d'une
confiance technique dans l'aptitude de
de nos installations à fonctionner
durant de T périodes puisque vous savez
qu'aux États-Unis des réacteurs ont
obtenu une licence à 80 15 ans en Europe
les finlandais de lovizza viennent
d'obtenir une autorisation fonctionn 60
ans en Suisse les réacteurs de besno qui
sont en fonctionnement ont été démarrés
en 1969- 1971 ça ne veut pas dire que
tout est acquis en France et que nous
pouvons faire exactement la même chose
mais vous voyez que
techniquement ce type d'installation
peut avoir un potentiel de vie qui
l'amène à fonctionner plus de 60 ans à
nous de trouver les conditions qui
répondent au cadre réglementairire et
aussi notre conviction d'industrielle
qui permettent de de d'envisager de
telles perspectives alors pour nous cela
change tout euh cela change évidemment
les perspectives de maintenance la
stratégie de maintenance ça nous permet
aussi de réouvrir des dossiers comme
l'augmentation de puissance euh ça pas
de sens de d'augmenter la puissance
d'une installation si vous avez une
perspective de euh fermeture à court
terme je CITIS tout à l'heure
l'augmentation de puissance des
réacteurs de 900 MW nous en avions
réalisé un certain nombre que nous avons
arrêté puisque les réacturs de 900 MW
devaient s'arrêter eux-mêmes donc il y
avait plus lieu de faire cet
investissement aujourd'hui la question
est reposée c'est vrai aussi sur
l'augmentation de la durée des cycles et
puis c'est un un élément cette
perspective de durée de fonctionnement
qui a un effet très important sur la
motivation de tous ceux qui comme moi
travaillent pour le parc nucléaire
puisque nous avons cette chance de
réfléchir à des projets de pérénisation
de notre outil de production merci de
votre attention
merci on posera la question après on les
laisse
exprimer monsieur dorzuk ou monsieur bar
il y a pas de Monsieur bar d'accord
j'aurais juste juste une petite question
qui fait écho au propos qui viennent
d'êre tenu le le programme Excel par
rapport à à Star 2025 que vous avez
évoqué c'est c'est le même sujet c'est
autre chose l'un est dans
l'autre je je peux répondre le programme
Excel été lancé plus particulièrement
pour le nucléaire ne9uf pour les
chantiers de du nucléaire ne9uf par
contre il est aussi une source
d'inspiration pour nous et et tout le le
sujet autour de la qualification des
partenaires industriel plus précise
versus une approche un peu généraliste
l'industrialisation d'opération de
maintenance sont des sujets pour
lesquels star 2025 s'est inspiré du plan
Excel donc vous avez des apports d'Excel
aussi ok merci Monsieur bar vous avez la
parole monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le Président de l'Autorité de
seté nucléaire mesdames et messieurs je
vous remercie beaucoup d'avoir d'avoir
convié le le gifen à à cette audition et
à participer à à vos travaux à
contribuer à vos
travaux sur la consommation le prix de
de
l'électricité peut-être avant de de
préciser les actions du gifen dans ce
cadre là quelques mots d'introduction
parce qu'autant vous connaissez très
bien EDF autant gifen est un une
organisation récente c'est le le
groupement des industriels français de
l'énergie nucléaire donc le syndicat
professionnel qui a été créé en
2018 par regroupement de quelques
organisations préexistantes et avec la
finalité de disposer finalement pour la
filière d'une organisation unique
représentative de l'ensemble de la
filière et qui est constitué
essentiellement d'entreprise je dis
essentiellement quelques organisations
professionnelles euh aujourd'hui le
gifen après 5 ans regroupe à peu près
500 500 membres
euh et euh et ça couvre toutes les
entreprises je dirais au cœur de la
filière les exploitants mais aussi les
fournisseurs de différents rangs et donc
l'enjeu c'est effectivement de faire
travailler collectif ensemble les
exploitants ça va être EDF mais aussi
Orano le CEA landandra ou framatum et
tous les fournisseurs ETI PME et vous
savez qu'on a un tissu de PME qui est
euh qui est à la fois très riche mais
fait de beaucoup de petites entreprise
familiale répartie dans les dans dans
beaucoup de territoires bien au-delà des
grandes installations de tête de la
filière donc la filière c'est c'est
connu fait à peu près un peu plus de
200000 200000 salariés au total
estimation on va dire
euh comme je l'ai dit c'est à peu près
500 peut-être un petit peu plus
d'entreprises au cœur et c'est
globalement 3000 entreprises qui
contribuent de près ou de loin à ces
activités alors un point à noter quand
même dans le contexte c'est c'est que
l'essentiel des des entreprises 80 % des
entreprises ne travaillent pas
exclusivement pour le nucléaire et au
contraire ont une part qui souvent est
min une part de nucléaire qui souvent
est minoritaire dans leur activité
travaille pour l'aéronautique travaille
pour d'autres secteurs c'est à la fois
évidemment une une opportunité
d'ouverture de standardisation
d'industrialisation des pratiques et en
même temps un vrai
enjeu comment dire
de de barrière à l'entrée de capacité à
exploiter des synergies euh qui nous
incombent euh et qui nous renvoie à nos
spécificités et à nos exigences propres
parce que pour beaucoup d'entre elles
c'est un tout petit volume et c'est des
exigences très particulières donc ça
c'est un élément de contexte important
euh dans nos activités c'est c'est aussi
un secteur qui exporte euh
structurellement alors
conjoncturellement l'an dernier ça a pas
tout à fait été le cas mais
structurellement c'est un c'est un
secteur qui exporte et 50 % des
entreprises à peu près de la filière euh
sont euh vivent à l'export c'est une
filière qui est complète et autant
pendant 25 ans on a très peu construit
de nouveaux réacteurs mais on s'est
concentrer sur l'exploitation du du
patrimoine qui avait été construit à la
fin du du siècle dernier sur les 25 ans
précédents mais ça a permis d'entretenir
une filière
complète sur les différents segments
contributeurs donc on garde une filière
complètement
autonome voilà alors le le jfen dans ce
contexte quelle est sa miss sa mission
c'est dans le dans le contexte de
relance ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
cette filière elle est en train de de
changer d'air avec le pays elle change
de point de consigne j'ai envie de dire
pour parler industriel
elle passe Étienne y a fait référence et
c'est aussi mobilisateur pour l'ensemble
des acteurs
passe d'un point de consigne de
fermeture de réacteur à un point de
consigne de prolongement du parc
s'ajoute à ça la perspective de
reconstruire des nouveaux réacteurs donc
de faire ce qu'on faisait les 25 ans
précédents et ce risque sur le gâteau de
de réouvrir aussi l'exploration de
nouvelles technologies avec des SMR des
Amr et en fait la filière est obligée de
regarder ça dans son
ensemble elle est obligée mais c'est
aussi une opportunité donc le le jfen
dans ce
contexte sert je l'ai dit à faire
travailler le collectif ensemble à aller
chercher de la performance collective
pour
relever le défi qui correspond à ce
changement de de point de consigne et il
sert à représenter je dirais la filière
dans son ensemble auprès de parties
prenantes à commencé par les pouvoirs
publics mais aussi les médias sur la
scène internationale européenne ou
autres alors pour contribuer sur le
sujet du jour en fait j'ai un petit peu
de mal à le distinguer du reste de du
point de consigne parce
qu'évidemment l'ensemble l'ensemble
industriel fait quand même relativement
un tout et c'est comme ça qu'on a qu'on
a travaillé euh dans le cadre d'un
programme qu'on a appelé le programme
match euh le nom venait du fait qu'on
voulait mesurer
euh la la manière d'assurer l'adéquation
entre la mobilisation des ressources et
et les besoins estimés pour faire face
aux différents programmes que je viens
de que je viens
d'évoquer c'est un travail qui qui a
pris 34 ans et dont le premier rapport a
été remis l'année dernière au
gouvernement qui a permis de constater
comme je le disais tout à l'heure que la
filière reste complète c'est qu' y a pas
segment industriel où il y a de grosses
lacunes à une exception près qui est la
fonderie en France pour la raison que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure c'est petit
volume exence particulièr pas de
perspective donc la
fonderie on achète dans le reste de
l'Europe mais pas en France le reste le
le secteur n'est pas sinistré je dirais
et et c'est normal parce qu'on a quand
même encore un des plus grands parcs
nucléaires au monde par contre on a
devant nous un enjeu de redéploiement de
croissance que l'on a estimé en volume
d'activité à environ 25 % sur les 10 ans
qui
viennent al après on a fait l'analyse
segment d'activité par segment
d'activité métier par métier 25 % de
volume d'activité c'estàd en en on a
travaillé en équivalent temp plein en
volume en unité d'œvre je dirais et sur
le périmètre qu'on a étudié qui sont les
métiers cœur les segments cœur qui
représent 125000 emplois sur les 200 et
quelques
1000 on est on a on a on a estimé que
sur les 10 ans qui viennent ça passerait
environ de 125000 à 155000 ce qui
représente une croissance de 25 %.
l'enjeu sur cette période ça veut dire
qu'il faut
euh à peu près
60000f emploi équivalent temp plein à à
à trouver sur les 10 ans la moitié pour
renouveler naturellement les départs et
l'autre moitié pour faire face à cette
croissance et et c'est en extrapolant à
l'ensemble de la filière et de ces
métiers moins spécifiques
euh les comptables les gestionnaires et
cetera que on est arrivé à une
estimation de 100000 emplois à trouver
euh sur les 10 ans qui viennent alors ça
c'est une estimation qui ne tient pas
compte euh des enjeux de productivité
d'ailleurs ce qu'on a mis en exerg dans
le cadre de cette étude c'est qu'il y
avait finalement trois leviers d'action
un premier levier d'action évidemment
qui est sur la mobilisation des
compétences euh celui qui est naturel
pour tout le monde recruter ce qui en
remontant la chaîne euh euh amène à des
problématiques de d'attractivité dans
les filières scientifiques
d'attractivité de manière plus générale
dans l'industrie d'ailleurs c'est un
sujet qu'on partage avec le reste de
l'industrie
euh le le deuxième levier est un levier
un levier de performance ettienne a a
évoqué le le levier de de la de la
performance et et évidemment il est très
complémentaire de la mobilisation des
ressources comment faire plus avec
autant de gens pour dire les choses
simplement le troisième levier est un
levier de soutenabilité économique d'une
filière qui a devant elle de gros
investissements euh de recrutement et
d'investissement dans dans l'outil
industriel et donc une partie de nos
activités pent sur la capacité de cette
filière à avoir les moyens euh et les
conditions en général d'assurer euh
d'assurer ses investissements alors la
prochaine mise à jour ça c'est un
exercice qui a vocation à être récurrent
puisque le but c'est de mesurer
progressivement la mise en adéquation
des ressources mobilisées avec avec les
les besoins estimé donc on va faire une
une mise à jour annuelle la prochaine
mise à jour de cet exercice match euh
sera fait pour l'été 2024 et on le fera
annuellement euh et il porte sur
l'intégralité du programme parce qu'on
peut évidemment pas distinguer euh à
l'intérieur de la filière les activités
qui portent sur le le parc existant et
sur les la constru de nouveau réacteur
ou ou ou autres ou autres ou autres
projets voilà al peut-être un point
complémentaire et pour terminer mon
propos liminaire euh ces ces travaux
nous ont amené à à identifier parce
qu'on travaille évidemment très
étroitement avec l'ensemble des
entreprises de la filière et le besoin
qui remonte très clairement c'est un
besoin de visibilité sur une
cadence sur en tout cas sur ce qui
permet de dimensionner les
investissements euh au niveau des
entreprises de la filière que ce soit
les recrutements chez les les les les
entreprises de de de main d'œuvre de
service de de chantier par exemple ou
que ce soit dans l'outil industriel
également chez les entreprises qui
fabrique des équipements et ça ça se
traduit par je reviens à ma notion de
point de consigne je vais prendre un
exemple sur les réacteurs neuf euh il
faut viser une cadence c'està que on a
pu entendre dire qu' qu'il fallait viser
de l'ordre de 1 à 1 et demi la capacité
de d'une filière française à à à
construire de 1 à 1 et demi réacteur par
an en France qu'on pourrait extrapoler
un petit peu pour pour être capable de
de de saisir les opportunités induites
euh de partenariat à l'étranger et donc
c'est c'est c'est une approche qui est
qui est très importante pour pour
l'industrie que de savoir sur quelle
rythme elle doit dimensionner ses
investissements je vous remercie pour
votre
attention merci Monsieur bar don la
parole à Monsieur
dorzuk Merci Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs et
madamees et messieurs
euh tout d'abord je suis bien évidment
très heureux même si c'est une
obligation d'être présent aujourd'hui à
cette réunion de commission d'enquête
sur un sujet qui est effectivement
majeur qui comporte à la fois le volet
ambitieux de développement de nouveau
nucléaire mais aussi le volet lié aux
parcs existants aux installations
existantes et j'ai compris que c'était
ce second volet qui était aujourd'hui
davantage à l'ordre du jour de notre
discussion et donc au regard de de ce
point je j'articulerai mon mon
intervention liminaire autour d'un thème
d'un sujet un seul sujet c'est celui du
besoin
d'anticipation pour ce qui concerne
l'ensemble des problématiques qui
peuvent se poser sur le parc des
installations euh existantes et parce
queon ne peut pas et c'est évident euh
distinguer la question de la production
d'électricité sans parler de
l'anticipation des enjeux de sûreté sur
le parc existant et c'est bien
évidemment ma mission en tant que
président de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et ce qui caractérise vraiment
de manière très forte hein le le le
nucléaire l'activité nucléaire en en
général c'est que c'est le domaine du
temps long et que ce qui peut-être
décidé sur un parc d'installation doit
être anticipé d'au moins 10 à 15 ans
pour qu'il puisse être mis en œuvre
qu'il s'agisse d'opérations de grand
carénage d'opération
de réexamen de sûreté des opérations
d'évolution des installations il faut il
faut du temps et donc le besoin
d'anticipation est extrement fort et et
cette anticipation ne concerne pas y
compris quand on regarde la
problématique de la production
électronucléaire ne concerne pas que les
réacteurs de DF elle concerne aussi ce
besoin d'anticipation concerne également
les installations du cycle du
combustible vous ne pouvez pas dans
votre réflexion dissocier la la la
réflexion sur le cycle du combustible de
la réflexion sur les réacteurs de
production d'électricité s'il n'y a pas
de combustible s'il n'y a pas de
capacité de retraiter les combustibles
s'il n'y a pas de capacité à entreposer
les combustibles usés c'est la
production d'électron nucléire qui est
bloquée on ne peut pas évacuer les
combustibles des centrales nucléaires
pour les acheminer vers les
installations du cycle du combustible
donc la production d'électronucléaire
c'est un système le système nucléaire
avec une composante de production à
travers les réacteurs mais une
composante également liée au
combustible et je pense que c'est
important que vous regardiez ce point
également dans votre
réflexion alors pour la SN lorsque l'on
regarde le sujet de
l'anticipation pour nous nous distingons
trois temporalités distinctes tout
d'abord ce que j'appelle ai euh un
besoin d'anticipation en terme de
sécurisation des installations
existantes au sens de leur
robustesse de leur résilience face au
risque d'aléa pendant la période qui qui
qui va aller jusqu'à l'horizon 2040
parce que jusqu'à 2040 il n'y aura pas
d'autres de manière significative
d'autres installations nucléaires en
service 2035 2040 à peu près l'horizon
on ne sait pas où sera le curseur et
donc il va falloir fonctionner avec les
installations actuelles et l'horizon de
2040 c'est aussi l'horizon qui est fixé
aujourd'hui dans la programmation
plurriannuelle de l'énergie en ce qui
concerne les installations du cycle du
combustible donc je prends bien
l'enveloppe des réacteurs de DF des
installations du cycle du combustible au
ranneau essentiellement et je dis il y a
d'abord un souci d'anticipation qui est
de faire en sorte que cet ensemble est
un fonctionnement qui soit sécurisé
jusqu'en je prend ce terme jusqu'en 2040
et je je dirais de de quoi il s'agit
hein c'est horizon 2040 c'est grosso
modo l'horizon pour ce qui concerne les
réacteurs pour les réacteurs les plus
anciens de l'atteinte des 60 ans donc
ensuite il y a un deuxième sujet
d'anticipation et et qui concerne les
deux à trois années qui viennent c'est
celui d'intégrer les les enjeux de
sûreté de Radioprotection et de
protection de l'environnement dans les
choix de politique énergétique qui vont
être faits dans les 2 3 ans qui viennent
parce que il y a C ces enjeux de sûrté
de radioprection et d'environnement vont
devoir être embarqués par les futurs
réacteurs les futures
installations pendant 60 peut-être 80
ans c'estàdire vont nous mener jusqu'à
la fin du siècle voire au-delà de la fin
du siècle et donc il faut intégrer cette
vision des enjeux de sûreté de
Radioprotection et de protection de
l'environnement dans les choix
politiques énergétique dans les 2 3 ans
qui viennent ce sera très difficile d'y
revenir après et je prendrai l'exemple
bien sûr du réchauffement climatique
tout à l'heure et puis enfin il y a
l'anticipation des enjeux de long terme
tous les espoirs de Monsieur duil et de
EDF ne ne seront pas suffisant pour
avoir un parc de réacteur qui soit
éternel il faudra bien les arrêter
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas ce qu'il a dit
hein mais je veux dire il faudra les
arrêter donc il faut anticiper ce moment
on ne sait pas exactement quand cela
sera ça ne concernera pas tous les
réacteurs en même temps mais la
spécificité du parc électronucléaire
français c'est que il a été construit
pour la quasi essentiel 90 % des
réacteurs dans une période très courte
une quinzaine d'années et donc ils
vieillissent tous en même temps et donc
dans une période très courte d'une
quinzaine d'années en prenant
l'hypothèse qu'ils iront tous jusqu'à
une certaine échéance qu'on ne connaît
pas exactement aujourd'hui ben ils
s'arrêteront en 15 ans et ça représente
une capacité une puissance de production
de considérable hein euh euh donc c'est
63 GW euh pour dire un chiffre c'est de
l'ordre je ne crois pas me tromper
d'environ 35pr2 en terme de puissance
35pr2 voilà ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
me faire 35 PR2 mais je veux dire que
pour fixer les grandeurs voilà ce ce
qu'il en est donc ces trois horizons de
temps la sécurisation c'est c'est c'est
c'est nécessaire tout de suite pour
pouvoir aller dans des conditions sûres
jusqu'à 2040 l'horizon 2040
l'anticipation des enjeux de sûreté dans
la définition de la politique
énergétique et l'anticipation des effets
long terme donc si on regarde le premier
sujet la sécurisation des installations
existantes jusqu'à l'horizon 2040 de
quoi s'agit-il prendre quelques exemples
pour illustrer le sujet et je n'irai pas
plus loin pour EDF par exemple il il
faut d'abord lever les les doutes qui
qui existent que nous avons nous-même
pointé du doigt dans un avis du 13 juin
2023 sur la la capacité de la du parc
actuel est jusqu'à 60 ans on a à travers
le 4e réexamen de sûreté des réacteurs
de 900 MW on s'est positionné sur le
passage de 40 à 50 ans on est en train
monsieur du l'a dit de d'instruire le
passage de 40 à 50 ans pour les
réacteurs de 1300 MW mais pour aller de
50 à 60 ans nous avons fait un travail
sur la base d'une analyse qui avait été
menée par EDF et à la demande du
Gouvernement sur il y a-t-il un risque
pour certains réacteurs de ne pas
pouvoir aller jusqu'à 60
et nous avons identifié neu situations
qui doivent être des situations à
investiguer par F sur neuf
réacteurs 9 sur 56 qui pourrait
éventuellement poser problème ça ne veut
pas dire que ça posera problème mais ce
sont des sujets prioritaires qui doivent
être traités par EDF en anticipation
sagit pas d'attendre pour pouvoir aller
jusqu'à 60 ans voilà un exemple de sujet
de
sécurisation deuxè sujet de sécurisation
peut-êtreons-nous l'occasion d'en parler
il y a bien évidemment on l'a bien vu
des sujets parfois de générique qui
peuvent porter sur le parc la corrosion
sous contrainte qui a été en grande
partie pas seulement mais à l'origine
des je diraisune faible production
électrique en en 2022 c'est un sujet qui
qui qui doit faire l'objet d'une
sécurisation il faut mettre en place un
pramme de maintenance de surveillance de
contrôle sur le parc pour que éviter
bien évidemment d'avoir une découverte
aussi importante dans le futur le sujet
N n'est pas clos hein la corrosion sous
contrainte et puis en ce qui toujours en
ce qui concerne le le le DF ben il
s'agit bien sûr de développer les les
programme de maintenance adapté et
d'achever les opérations de grand
carénage vous l'avez bien vu elle
s'étalent par par palier et ça va durer
de de très nombreuses années c'est une
un moyen de sécuriser le fonctionnement
du parc pour les installations du cycle
du combustible et ben il va falloir et
et au Renault en est tout à fait
conscient sécuriser le fonctionnement
des installations actuelles il y a eu un
certain nombre de difficultés sur
l'installation Melox qui est
l'installation qui produit le MOX à
partir du du retraitement réalisé à la
Hague bon
je tout la totalité des experts de
l'exploitant est convaincu qu'il y a un
besoin de sécurisation de cette
installation si méx ne fonctionne pas
c'est un risque de saturation des
capacités d'entreposage des combustibles
usés à la Hague donc c'est vraiment
majeur il faut vraiment le le le traiter
pendant toute cette période et puis il
faut bien sûr aussi
éviter le risque de saturation parce
qu'il y a quand même chaque année
saturation des piscines d'entreposage de
laacle une quantité notamment de MOX usé
qui vient s'additionner au au au
combustible usé qui est entreposé et on
atteint là plus de 95 % de de saturation
des piscines ça pourrait donc être un
sujet à l'horizon 2030 2035 il faudra
trouver des capacité d'entreposage
complémentaire dans des conditions sûres
pour éviter un problème d'embolie sur la
totalité par voilà ça ce sont des sujets
de sécurisation dont il faut se
préoccuper immédiatement deuxème domaine
d'illustration c'est l'intégration des
enjeux de sûreté et de radioprotection
et d'environnement dans les choix
énergétiques à faire dans les 2 3 ans et
donc là il s'agit d'une certaine manière
de se positionner sur le
futur énergie nucléaire post 2040 donc
on a bien vu parmi les enjeux en ce qui
concerne le parc nucléaire et bien il il
y a la question de est-ce qu'on peut
aller au-delà de 60 ans on a évoqué
l'horizon 70 80 ans est-ce que c'est
possible donc on a engagé un travail
avec EDF qui a été élargi récemment au
CEA avec l'appui de l'IRSN pour
identifier les points sensibles qui
pourraient être des points dirriimant en
ce qui concerne la poursuite
d'exploitation au-delà de 60 ans c'est
notamment toutes les le cas des
composants irremplaçables on peut
remplacer un transformateur mais on peut
pas remplacer la cuve du du réacteur ou
très difficilement remplaçable il y a
des des milliers de kilomètres de câble
électrique s'il ne vieillissent pas dans
de bonnes conditions de là de 60 ans ça
peut être un problème donc il y a ce
besoin d'identification des des des des
points sensibles sur l'installation ce
travail est engagé
DF doit fournir un certain nombre de de
de de résultats d'investigation des
méthodes de pour pouvoir justifier la la
tenue éventuelle au-delà de 60 ans et
nous avons pris l'engagement de prendre
une position sur les méthodes à
développer fin 2026 c'est-à-dire de
donner de la visibilité par anticipation
c'estàd on va pas se prononcer fin 2026
sur le fait que le parc nucléaire
pourrait à 60 ans mais on se mettra
d'accord sur les sujets pour lesquels il
faut mener des travaux éventuellement de
recherche de d'approfondissement des des
justifications des méthodes de
justification peut-être les faire
évoluer en s'inspirant notamment des
expériences à l'étranger c'est possible
mais on aura identifié tous ces points
fin 2026
il y a pour ce qui concerne toujours le
parc nucléaire il y a la question des
enjeux liés au dérèglement climatique à
partir de 2040 si les installations
actuelles poursuivent leur
fonctionnement elles pourrai être sur
des sites qui accueiller accueilleront
pardon des opères de donc il y a déjà
une pression sur le milieu liée au aux
installations actuelles pression qui
sera accentuée par le fait qu'il y aura
d'autres installations en même temps qui
seront installé sur sur les mêmes sites
on pense notamment aux grands axes comme
le Ron ou comme la Loire qui peuvent
être des axes où il y a déjà pas mal
d'installations nucléaires avec des des
des sujets d'impact sur le milieu en
terme de prélèvement de la ressource en
eau avec une une vision territorialisée
parce que il faut partager cette
ressource mais aussi d'impact sur le
milieu en terme de rejet voir d'impact
sur les installations en terme de
capacité d'entreposage des effluentss
pendant une période de temps suffisante
en attendant que il y ait un débit de de
rivière suffisant pour pouvoir les
diluer donc il y a ces enjeux là il faut
les anticiper parce que ils vont
conditionner certains choix de
conception du futur parc racteur c'est
maintenant que la conception est
finalisée pour les réacteurs qui sont en
service en 2040 il faut intégrer l'enjeu
du réchauffement climatique maintenant
ça sera trop tard après voilà et puis il
y a il y a bien
évidemment des enjeux qui sont liés au
au cycle du combustible lui-même il y a
des installations qui sont aujourd'hui
euh donc effectivement assez assez
anciennes entre guillemets qui vont
nécessiter un peu de la même manière que
que le ça a été fait sur le parc DF un
espèce de grand carénage sur les
installations de lague et il va falloir
vraisemblablement au-delà de 2040
définir la vision en ce qui concerne le
le futur
retraitement les installations d'orano
ne sonont pas éternels non plus elles
peuvent poursuivre leur fonctionnement
2040 moyenant un grand carénage mais à
un moment donné il va falloir les
remplacer et donc il faut anticiper
quelles sont dans les enjeux dans les
choix de politique énergétique quelle
sera la stratégie de retraitement est-ce
que ça sera du monoecyclage est-ce que
ça sera du multirecyclage est-ce qu'on
visera à progresser sur la fermeture du
cycle du combustible parce que tous ces
choix vont dimensionner la la
l'installation future en terme y compris
technologique donc et ça il faut faire
désori orentation dans les 2 3 ans qui
viennent il y a au moins 10 à 15 ans
d'études avant de définir l'installation
qui devra être construite pour pouvoir
succéder aux installations danouag donc
un besoin d'anticipation extrêmement
fort je termine sur les sur le long
terme donc sur le long terme le vrai
enjeu c'est bien évident d'anticiper ce
que on appelle en général l'effet
falaise c'est-à-dire le fait que à un
moment donné sur une période
relativement courte B l'ensemble des
réacteurs actuels don je rappelis la la
puissance hein
devront être mis à l'arrêt et et ça bien
évidemment c'est sur une période très
courte ça ça suppose de de faire des
choix de politique énergétique pas
nécessairement nucléaire hein mais de
faire des choix de politique énergétique
qui permettent surtout dans un contexte
et vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président de développement des usages
électriques donc peut-être des besoins
en électricité plus importants dans une
volonté forte de de souveraineté et de
décarbonation de de de l'économie donc
il faut il faut pas se rater certain
maniè donc donc là moi mon message c'est
vraiment très fort sur cette vision à
long terme il faut anticiper le fait
qu'on va perdre le parc nucléaire actuel
à un moment donné
et et pour cela ben je pense qu'il faut
avoir une une politique énergétique
robuste qui ne repose pas sur sur trop
de de choses je dirais possibles il faut
que ça soit
vraiment quelque chose de solide de
convaincant parce que je si l'efficacité
énergétique que l'on que l'on attend
n'est pas là si le développement des
énergies renouvelables qu'on attend
n'est pas là si le le le le
développement des nouveaux réacteurs
n'est pas là et ben il pourrait y avoir
la tentation de dire B finalement face
au besoins face à la demande
d'électricité il y a une solution c'est
de poursuivre encore le fonctionnement
des réacteurs actuels d'aller encore
plus loin il ne faudrait pas que le la
durée de fonctionnement d'exploitation
des réacteurs actuels soit la variable
d'ajustement d'une politique énergétique
qui aurait été mal calibrée c'est
vraiment le message d'anticipation que
nous portons en tant que autorité de
sreté nucléaire mon
prés j'aurais une question sur le
dernier point mais je laisse la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur et puis on va
merci monsieur le Président c'est vrai
que merci messieur pour vos vos propos
liminires moi j'ai énormément de
questions donc je vais essayer de pas
monopoliser trop la parole mais c'est
vrai qu' ça suscite beaucoup de
questions l'anticipation sur laquelle
vous reveniez monsieur dzuk c'est la
volonté de notre commission d'enquête
aussi parce que d'une façon générale
dans les politiques publiques souvent on
n'anticipe pas assez donc on est souvent
dans des gestion à court terme d'une
façon générale et là on sait bien que
c'est du temps long et du du temps voir
très long et quand on parle de 6080 ans
c'est vrai que c'est c'est long euh
voilà
donc question
qui vous concerne notamment tous les
deux monsieur dille et Monsieur dzuk par
rapport à la prolongation
des des réacteurs
existants on parle de 50 ans 60 ans
peut-être 80 qu'est-ce qui nous
distingue des États-Unis où ils ont
déjà effectivement prongé pas mal de
réacteurs à 60 ans à ma connaissance et
il commence à le faire pour 80
ans est-ce qu'il y a des éléments de
réglementation purement français ou
voilà de contraintes réglementair ou qu'
fixé qui sont plus contraignantes qu'aux
États-Unis qui expliquerait que on a
peut-être un peu plus de mal à prorroger
ces ces réacteurs plus longtemps après
sur la
production moi j'étais surpris par vos
chiffres monsieur duteille 2025 2026 on
bouge pas de 365 alors qu'on a déjà
atteint 400 et quelques alors bien sûr
on a fermé fenheim alors fenheim moi
j'aimerais savoir si ça pourrait
seouvrir limite si on décidait de
rouvrir F aujourd'hui est-ce que avec
des gros investissements on y arriverait
est-ce que ça coûterait moins cher que
de faire un nouveau réacteur j'en sais
rien c'est c'est une question que sur
lesquell j'aimerais avoir votre avis et
on va ouvrir Flamanville euh donc
normalement courant courant l'année 2024
quand est-ce que flamandville produira
euh au maximum à son maximum est-ce que
c'est courant 2025 et qu'est-ce qui fait
que on joint pas ces 400 tawh euh qu'on
a déjà produit avec
notre euh avec nos réacteurs actuels euh
alors après je vais avoir des questions
sur la corrosion sous contrainte euh
est-ce qu'on est les seuls dans le monde
à avoir ça ou est-ce que d'autres pays
l' connu
euh est-ce que euh est-ce qu'on était
obligé de tout fermer de fermer je crois
que c'est 22 réacteurs euh non je sais
plus combien c'est euh tout en même
temps
qui a pris cette décision sur la base de
quel document quel élément voilà et
quelle temporalité à quel moment ces
décisions ét prises moi j'aimerais bien
avoir
le le détail de ce qui a été fait à ce
moment-là et de de cette décision qui a
été prise parce
que sans doute que ça existait avant
c'est corrosions sous contrainte ou
est-ce que on les a découvert lors d'une
visite je sais pas voilà j'aimerais
avoir un peu plus de détails sur ce
sujet
là
alors je vais prendre la première
question mais je je pense que les autres
sont essentiellement pour Monsieur Dutel
et je pense que nous interviendrons tous
les deux sur la corrupion sous contrat
alors qu'est-ce qui distingue la France
notamment des États-Unis en ce qui
concerne la la poursuite d'exploitation
des des réacteurs tout d'abord il y a il
y a une donnée qui qui est parfois m
connue mais qui est très importante
c'est que aux États-Unis les réacteurs
disposent de licence qui ont des durées
limitées c'est-à-dire que l'Autorité de
sûreté américaine a accordé une licence
pour 40 ans et et au bout de 40 ans ça
s'arrête et donc elle est obligée de
prendre un une nouvelle licence pour
accepter la la poursuite d'exploitation
et elle le fait avec des pas de 20 ans
et donc elle l'a fait pour la
quasittalité des réacteurs en tout cas
beaucoup qui sont plus anciens que les
nôtres et donc qui sont plus proches les
40 ans elle l'a fait pour aller de 40 à
60 ans et certains exploitants pas
beaucoup mais quelques-uns ont
souhaitait avoir
une apporter des preuves pour avoir une
autorisation pour aller de 60 à 80 ans
aucun des réacteurs américains n'a plus
de 60 ans hein donc ne pensez pas qu'il
y a des réacteurs américains qui sont
entre 60 et 80 ans ce n'est pas le cas
donc mais ils ont un système où il faut
un acte de la part de l'autorité pour
accepter une poursuite d'exploitation
pendant 20 ans ce n'est pas le cas en
France les autorisations que nous
délivrons n'ont pas de de de durée
limitée lorsque l'on autorise le
fonctionnement d' reeur il est
autorisé il n'y a pas de de de de
limite on n pas fixé à 40 ans mais on a
dans la réglementation française et
c'est pas d'ailleurs uniquement dans la
réglementation française puisque c'est
issu d'une directive européenne et c'est
une recommandation internationale nous
avons le principe que chaque 10 ans nous
faisons un réexamen de sûreté pour
regarder l'état de installation d'abord
conformité et puis nous avons la volonté
chaque 10 ans de nous interroger sur
quelles sont les améliorations de sûreté
qui peuvent être apportés au réacteur et
d'une certaine manière c'est quelque
chose qui est un rendez-vous qui qui qui
qui matérialise le fait que on on
poursuit le fonctionnement pendant
encore une période de 10 ans c'est et
nous l'avons fait d'abord pour les
réacteurs les plus anciens de de 900 MW
quand ils sont arrivés à leurs 40 ans
dans dans un un contexte qui était
effectivement un peu particulier puisque
à l'origine de la construction du parc
la période de 40 ans avait été indiqué
comme étant la période normale de de
durée de de fonctionnement et donc il y
avait un peu un symbole de passer
au-delà des 40 ans et c'est et c'est ce
que nous avons traité à travers des
décisions d'amélioration de la sûreté
des réacteurs de 900 MW pour se
rapprocher le plus possible des facteur
de dernière génération c'est-à-dire le
Pr en terme de sûreté et ça c'est un
c'est quelque chose auquel nous tenons
collectivement c'est de dire il n'y a
pas en France de parc électronucléaire
de réacteurs nucléaires en tout cas il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas vocation à avoir
des niveaux de sûreté différent n
nousous nous faisons en sorte que le
parc ancien se rapproche autant que
possible du
réacteur le plus performant en terme de
sûreté qui qui est le P et ça c'est une
condition d'acceptabilité du nucléaire
faire en sorte que que ce que ne font
pas les États-Unis alors ce que ne font
pas les États-Unis ça veut pas dire
qu'ils font pas d'amélioration mais il
n'y a pas ce ce processus que je viens
de vous décrire en profondur et donc
tant que ce tant que nous sommes dans ce
processus alors 40 ans ça a été
particulièrement important en terme de
de mise à niveau mais dans les
discussions que nous avons notamment
avec EDF on voit bien et nous-même avec
l'IRSN que le le le gap qui a été
franchi lors de la 4e visite décennale
n'est pas n'est pas de représentatif
d'un Gap qui serait à franchir à la 5e à
la 6e puisque on aura mis à niveau le le
parc le le plus ancien par rapport au
réacteur de de l'pr il y aura
vraisemblablement des améliorations
encore il y aura certainement à prendre
en compte l'impact du réchauffement
climatique mais ce ne sera pas de la
même ampleur et donc ce que nous disons
nous c'est que dans le système qui est
le nôtre grâce à cette amélioration de
du niveau de sûreté que nous avons
réalisé notamment au passage symbolique
des 40 ans qui était bon ensuite ben
nous prendrons des décisions par période
de 10 ans mais nous voulons éclairer
parce que il faut donner plus de
d'anticipation ce qui pourrait se passer
bien avant la la la 5e visite décennale
sur qu'est-ce qui pourrait se passer à
la 6e voire à la 7e d'où le travail que
nous avons engagé sur la durée de
fonctionnement quelle est la durée de
fonctionnement possible du parc français
et bien évidemment c'est les travaux de
recherche dont je parlais tout à l'heure
d'identification des points faibles la
le l'exploitation du retour d'expérience
de ce qu'on fait nos homologues à
l'étrangers les Américains les
Suisses voilà on travaille avec eux et
et on prendra les décisions lorsque nous
aurons les éléments qui sont éclairé
mais sur le principe nous n'avons pas
fixé de limite ça pourrait être 60 60
peut-être 70 peut-être 80 ans dès lors
que c'est peut-être justifié du point de
vue de de la sûreté donc voyez-vous il y
a pas
il y a pas une
différence structurelle entre ce que
nous faisons et ce que faisons nos
homologues mais la méthode est pas la
même je vais continuer
avec le point concernant fenheim alors
FIM produisait aux alentours de 10 TWh
par an sur le parc
aujourd'hui il n'est plus techniquement
envisageable de redémarrer Fessenheim
parce que des des actions euh
irréversibles ont été euh menées sur
l'installation dans le cadre de de son
euh déantellement euh je je je mets de
côté le fait qu'on a démonté une partie
des équipements et cetera parce que dans
l'absolu euh on pourrait toujours les
remplacer mais vous avez une euh
décontamination du circuit primaire qui
a été réalisée avec euh des produits
extrêmement corrosifs pour retirer euh
la la la contamination et donc faciliter
les opérations de de démantellement de
déconstruction qui rendrait aujourd'hui
la remise en service de de
l'installation même si théoriquement on
pouvait tout reconstruire autour
extrêmement problématique et puis
l'installation n'a plus non plus
d'autorisation de fonctionnement donc il
faudrait imaginer tout un processus pour
pour la redémarrer alors les les
chiffres de de production que je vous ai
indiqué j'ai peut-être pas été assez
précis sur le sujet sont hors
flamandville 3 les les 300 45 3 5 TWh
Flam enville 3 étant un des éléments qui
permet d'aller vers une une production
de de 400 terw avec les augmentations de
puissance l'allongement de la durée des
cycles et cetera alors Flamanville va
démarrer en 2024 va connaître un un
premier cycle de fonctionnement à
l'issue de laquelle nous allons faire
une visite de contrôle très approfondi
parce que ça fait partie de des règles
également de manière un peu schématique
on on fait une visite qui s'apparente à
une visite décennale après un cycle de
fonctionnement de manière à faire un
contrôle très approfondi de
l'installation et et vérifier son
comportement l'absence de défaut c'est
ce qui a été fait sur tous les réacteurs
du parc c'est ce qui est fait sur
flamandville à l'issue de cette visite
approfondie qui aura lieu vers 25 26 la
centrale continu enfin
aura un cycle de de fonctionnement
nominal et et à ce moment-là on aura une
production qui sera un peu inférieure à
à 10 TWh par an aux alentours de de 8
TWh
par alors concernant la la corrosion
sous contrainte la la
corrosion il y a aucune aucune
raison pour que il y ait pas de
phénomène de corrosion sous contrainte
qui se produit sur d'autres d'autres
réacteurs dans le monde puisque la
corrosion sous contrainte est lié à la
conjonction d'un d'un matériau plus ou
moins sensible à la Corion sous
contrainte d'un milieu chimique en
l'occurrence circuit primaire qui permet
le développement de la corusion sous
contrainte et à l'existence d'une
contrainte mécanique sur le matériau
donc le fait de pouvoir réunir
l'ensemble de ces de ces éléments
ailleurs sur d'autres centrales dans le
monde à l'évidence c'est tout à fait
possible alors euh
euh chez nous ça s'est réalisé ou pas
vous dises que c'est possible mais
est-ce que à votre connaissance euh il y
a il y a des pays qui ont subi les mêmes
contraintes que nous alors à notre
connaissance ont été euh a été
communiqué un cas de corrosion sous
contrainte sur alors là il faut être un
peu prudent c'est corrosion sous
contrainte vous pouvez en avoir à
plusieurs plusieurs endroits en fait là
on parle de corrosion sous contrainte
sur des circuits sur des tuyoteries
parce qu'il existait des cas de
corrosion sous contrainte sur d'autres
composants qui n'avaient pas eu le même
euh les les les mêmes conséquences c'est
qu'on connaît un peu partout sur
des tuyoteries euh en l'occurrence un
circuit relié au circuit primaire il y a
un cas au Japon de corrosion sous
contrainte extrêmement localisé qui
était qui étit publié
euh après comment dire tout dépend de
qui au Japon et il y en a combien en
France euh ah on en a trouvé beaucoup
sur plusieurs réacteurs mais enfin il y
a eu un défaut de fabrication en fait
face à
le processus est le suivant vous
réalisez des contrôles sur votre
installation euh vous trouvez une
indication et et cette indication se
révèle une fissure là vous avez deux
approches possibles
euh soit vous réparez et vous
redémarrez soit vous analysez les causes
vous déterminez que c'est de la
corrosion sous contrainte vous réparez
et vous redémarrez donc dans des cas où
les réparations auraient été faites sans
qu'on analyse précisément les causes
métallurgiques du défaut vous pouvez
avoir rencontré des cas de corrosion
sous contrainte sans euh que euh la
corrosion sous contrainte ait été
identifiée nous sommes allés à euh nous
avons analysé les causes je vous
expliquer comment ça s'est produit en
fait c'est dans le cadre des contrôles
euh que nous réalisons en l'occurence
CIT une visite décennale euh et c'est ça
concernait euh un réacteur de civau euh
nous avons euh découvert dans le cadre
de nos contrôles descénaux une
indication sur un circuit qui est euh
euh circuit d'injection de sécurité donc
connecté au circuit primaire une
indication c'est un écho
sur un système de d'examen non
destructif donc cet écho il doit être
interprété et
pour
euh y voir plus clair pour avoir une
certitude sur la nature de cette
indication nous avons demandé
l'autorisation à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire de
déposer la portion de circuit concerné
et nous l'avons analysé dans un
laboratoire métallurgique qui peut
analyser des pièces déposées de centrale
nucléaire pour déterminer ce dont il
s'agissait donc il s'agissait d'une
fissure et d'une fissure dont la
signature si je puis dire était de la
corrosion sous contrainte donc vous
voyez que l'approche mais qui
l'approche française consiste à
investiguer jusqu'au bout pour connaître
l'origine ensuite l'analyse que nous
avons fait a révélé la possibilité que
cette courure sous
contrainte soit n'affecte pas uniquement
ce réacteur puisque nous avavions aucun
élément qui montrait qu'il y avait une
spécificité sur ce réacteur donc nous
avons étendu le programme de contrôle
d'abord au réacteur
de du même type que civo pour ça il a
fallu les arrêter et puis nous avons
proposé un programme d'investigation
complémentaire à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire d'autant plus que nous avons
compris assez vite que les autres
réacteurs du type N4 du même type que
civo étaiit
euh étaiit affectés aussi ici euh la la
4 excusez-moi c'est quelle puissance
1450 MW ce sont les réacteurs de civo et
de chouud la
cause principale de de la la corrosion
sous contrainte sur ces réacteurs et et
sur des réacteurs un peu voisins de 1300
MW était lié au design des lignes qui
créaient des conditions de de de mélange
d'eau chaude et d'eau froide qui
euh favorisit la la la sous contrainte
notre approche a été en responsabilité
d'arrêter ces réacteurs le temps de
connaître
précisément
l'effet l'impact de de de ces
indications sur la sûreté de
l'installation d'en comprendre les
causes et ensuite d'entamer des
processus de réparation et de
justification au fur à mesure que nous
avons compris les causes et que nous
avons évalué l'impact des indications de
corrosion sous contrainte des fissures
de corrosion sous contrainte sur nos
circuits nous avons pu passer d'une
démarche de
réparation dans la totalité des cas à
une démarche de réparation ou de
justification pour une période donnée et
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu industrialiser
et sortir progressivement de
cette crise de la corrosion sous
contrainte alors elle a deux
caractéristiques si je puis dire la
première est liée euh à l'aspect
standardisé du parc des réacteurs de DF
qui est un grand
avantage dans énormément de situations
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de la
possibilité d'utiliser des procédures
totalement standardisé et cetera c'est
un grand avantage ça peut aussi être une
menace quand un problème se produit sur
un réacteur et et qu'il est lié au
design du réacteur lui-même puisque vous
pouvez il se propager sur l'ensemble des
réacteurs c'est ce qui s'est produit
dans dans le cas de la corrosion sous
contrainte et puis le deuxième point
c'est
que
l'approche française en matière de
sûreté et je pense que personne peut
contester le bénéfice de cette approche
consiste à réparer plutôt que essayer de
justifier donc nous sommes allés vers
une approche volontariste de
réparation de ces circuits
euh de
compréhension de manière approfondie
aussi des phénomènes avant de justifier
et je pense que c'est bénéfique à la
sûreté juste une question sur sur sur ce
sujet monsieur dorzuc a centré son
propos sur la notion d'anticipation
est-ce qu'à partir de ce de de ce cas de
la corrosion sous contrainte euh des
investigations ont été réalisées euh
plus largement sur les sur les proc
process pour essayer de détecter par
anticipation des points des points
faibles ou ou des des des des éléments
de de dégradation en cours est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que cette démarche a
été
ou engagée ou approfondie si elle
existait déjà oui alors et sur quel
sujet par exemple d'abord elle elle
existe elle existait déjà
euh puisque bon nous avons d'une part
des programmes de contrôle sur nos nos
réacteurs qui sont extrêmement
conséquents et et qu'au-delà des
programmes de
contrôle
régulier nous avons aussi un un
programme d'investigation complémentaire
qui vise à aller voir sur des parties de
l'installation qui ne font pas l'objet
de maintenance préventive ou qui ne sont
pas contrôlé puisqu'on contrôle pas tout
quand même s'il y a pas des angles morts
donc cette cette approche là elle vise à
nous garantir de la découverte euh d'une
d'une mauvaise surprise si je puis dire
euh quelque part c'est le programme de
contrôle qui a permis euh de détecter la
présence de la corrosion sous contrainte
on l'a pas détecté par hasard on l'a
détecté parce que nous sommes allés
contrôler euh une partie du circuit ce
qui nous a surpris c'est son caractère
générique
euh et et qui en a fait qui fait qu'elle
avait une ampleur particulière euh bien
sûr que euh nous en avons tiré nous
continuons tirer le retour d'expérience
pour d'une part nous assurer que des
situation de corrosion sous contrainte
ne sont pas présentes sur d'autres
parties de l'installation donc nous
avons un
programme qui est est en cours de
déploiement qui élargit à d'autres
parties de l'installation que ces
circuits connectés au circuits primaires
dont j'ai parlé qui était au cœur de de
de la crise de la Corion s contrainte
euh qui va s'étaler sur plusieurs
plusieurs années et naturellement
ça a conduit à engager chez nous une
réflexion pour aller au-delà sur de
possibles angles morts dans nos
programmes
d'investigation dans une démarche à dire
qui
est inhérente à toute toute démarche de
maintenance c'est un peu mon métier mais
la maintenance n'est jamais
figée ce serait une erreur de de le
penser c'est quelque chose qui doit en
permanence s'enrichir du retour
d'expérience celui-ci je vous l'accorde
a été douloureux mais il est
normalintégrer les résultats pour
élargir adapter nos programmes de
contrôle allez-y je je passe la parole à
mes collèg pour répondre à la question
sur la corrosion sous contrain je
voudrais compléter les propos de
Monsieur Dutel bon tout d'abord le
phénomène de corrosion sous contraintes
il existe dans le parc mondial c'est il
faut distinguer dans le parc par les
technologies de réacteurs là la
découverte qui a été faite c'est sur le
parc français qui est exclusivement des
réacteurs à ha
souspression le parc mondial comporte
bien sûr des réacteurs à ha spression
mais aussi d'autres
technologies il y a notamment les
réacteurs à eau bouillantees une
technologie différente que nous n'avons
pas en France et qui a fait l'objet il y
a 10 15 ans de découverte massive de
corrosion sous contrainte à l'échelle
mondiale moi je suis allé au Japon j'ai
discuté du sujet avec mon mon homologue
expliquer qu'ils avaient été obligés
d'arrêter certains réacteurs à eau
bouillante plusieurs mois voire une
année pour traiter le cas de la
corrosion sous contrainte j'en ai parlé
avec mon collègue américain mon collègue
allemand c'est arrivé aussi sur leur
réacteur auouillante donc la corrosion
sous contrainte c'est quelque chose qui
existe sur le parc nucléaire
mondial la la chose nouvelle c'est que
ça n'avait jamais été découvert sur pour
ces parties-là de circuit sur des
réacteurs à Ha souspression voilà donc
ça c'est l'élément nouveau ensuite
monsieur Dutel a bien expliqué que les
premières analyses sur les causes de ce
développement de de corrosion sous
contrainte sont lié à des géométries de
lignes particulières et notamment sur
les réacteurs les plus récents du parc
les réacteurs de 1450 MW et de 1300 et
d'une après toutes les investigations
qui ont été mené il s'avère que les
réacteurs les plus anciens du de 900 MW
sont très peu voire pas de corrosion
sous contrainte et quand on regarde
l'état du parc des réacteurs à haut
souspression dans le monde et ben il y a
pas la géométrie des réacteurs de 1300
et et de 1450 qui est finalement une
adaptation française des réacteurs de
900 MW on a plutôt dans le monde des
réacteurs de 900 MW de type 900 MW en
France et donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas une surprise d'une certaine manière
même si il faut rester prudent et je
pense que il faut faut que les contrôles
soient faits avec les outils de contrôle
qu'il faut et peut-être nos homologues
trouveront-ils enfin les exploitants
trouveront-ils à l'étranger des cas de
corrosion sous contrainte et on diffuse
beaucoup d'information et une partage
d'information deedf nous l'avons fait
avec les autres autorités pour que des
contrôles soient ciblés sur les
installations des réacteurs à ha
spression à l'étranger peut-être il y
aura-il des découvertes dans le futur
mais c'est pas c'est pas totalement
incompréhensible que il n'en est pas
trouvé si les réacteurs sont plutôt de
technologie de type 9 MW parce que nous
même nous n'avons pas trouvé sur les
réacteurs de 900 MW donc voyez-vous je
pense qu'il faut il faut bien prendre
l'ensemble de de du
sujet merci on va donner la parole à
enriabanel madame S et Alexandre qui est
là-bas oui toujours sur la corrosion s
sous
contrainte les fissures ont été réparées
je suppose par des des chaudronniers
spécialisés
bon est-ce que les compétences et les
ressources internes étaient suffisantes
ou a-t-il fallu faire appel à d'autres
compétences externes d'autres pays par
exemple je vous dis ça parce que en
2016 déjà euh quand la commission des
affaires économiques s'était déplacé à
Chalon sursonne pour visiter une
entreprise que s'appelait Areva on nous
avait déjà signalé qu'il y avait
quelques difficultés de recrutement pour
des chaudourniers
spécialisés et on se trouve donc 6 ans
après avec me semble-t-il une
problématique donc de compétenence qu'on
n pas et qu'il a fallu aller chercher
ailleurs pour effectivement réparer
est-ce que c'est exact ou pas Madame
sé vous cumulez les questions président
d'accord merci président merci mer
messieurs de vos prestations devant nous
cet après-midi j'ai deux questions l'une
au nom de notre collègue qui a été
obligé de nous quitter François bonau et
vous l'excuserit donc c'est la première
question qu'en'est-il des problématique
de
surtransposition qui s'impos au domaine
du nucléaire notamment en terme de
contrôle et d'entretien c'est la
première question deuxème question c'est
la mienne je veux m'adresser à vous
monsieur monsieur duteille
euh je dirais que nos deux expériences
dramatiques de notre Floren et DF je
veux parler de flamamentville et je veux
parler de incley P en
Grande-Bretagne vu ces deux expériences
malheureuses quels sont les gages de
sérieux de réussite que vous pouvez
donner à la fois à nous les
parlementaires mais aussi à
l'état concernant ces perspectives que
vous nous brossez et pour lesquel donc
si vous avez le feu vert vous les
exercerez est-ce qu'il y aura des points
à datte est-ce que vous reviendrait
devant le Parlement est-ce que vous
pourrez fournir des rapports de façon à
ce qu'on soit
sûr que la feuille de route que kedf au
cour DF demain ne soit pas encore maillé
de quelques catastroph dramatique comme
les deux cas que je viens de citer je
vous remercie
oui oui bonjour messieur merci de d'être
devant nous aujourd'hui plusieurs
questions d'abord sur la question de la
corrosion sous contrainte si j'ai bien
compris ce que disait l'exploitant c'est
à l'occasion d'une découverte par
l'exploitant d'une difficulté ensuite
vous en avez informé l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire donc c'était une
autoévaluation qui vous a conduit à
informer l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
ensuite vous nous avez dit que vous
aviez proposé vous-même me semble-t-il
des solutions de remédiation et
vous-même une enquête élargie en fait ma
question elle est simple c'est quelles
sont les relations dans ce moment-là
entre l'exploitant et le régulateur et
j'ajoute un tiers qui n'est jamais très
loin qui est la question de l'IRSN qui
en plus nous occupe en ce moment pour
essayer de comprendre si l'IRSN a jouer
un rôle aussi et lequel est-ce qu'il
elle a été sollicitée par l'autorité de
sûrté nucléaire par vous-même côté EDF
pour son Expertis et CEA donc pour bien
comprendre en fait comment le dans le
temps pour prolonger la question du
rapporteur les choses se sont se sont
passées moi deuxième question sur la
prolongation de la durée de vie des
centrales est-ce que chez EDF
aujourd'hui il y a des plans à 20 ans
enfin 40 ans où est-ce que vous où
est-ce que vous en êtes côté EDF
c'està-dire sur quoi vous travaillez
quel sont vos hypothèses de travail tout
à l'heure le président de l'Autorité de
sclire disait qu'il y avait des pièces
qui étaient qui étaient irremplaçables
qui avaient un caractère irremplaçable
donc est-ce que vous vous mettez une
espèce de limite absolue ou sur quoi
vous
travaillez aussi sur la même sujet sur
la prolongation de la durée de vie on
parlait d'un effet falaise tout à
l'heure l'effet falaise en effet c'est
le fait que le parc s'arrête à un moment
mais du coup si le parc s'arrête il faut
démantel ce parc est-ce qu'on a une idée
on parle du coût de l'énergie en 2035
2050 ça coûte combien au gigwh
supplémentaire le moment où on va démler
autant de centrale d'un seul coup et
est-ce que vous avez est-ce que vous
avez travaillé sur sur sur ces ces
sujets là
donc je finis pardon sur une question
parce que c'est ce qu'a dit à la fin le
le président de l'Autorité de chclire
sur la durée d'exploitation comme risque
de variable d'ajustement en fait est-ce
que vous avez peur à un moment que votre
successeur se retrouve dans la situation
inconfortable où il doit fermer quelque
chose avec des conséquences terribles
sur la vie de la nation parce que vous
aurez repéré quelque chose ou que vous
direiez maintenant c'est stop pour cette
durée parce que c'est ça que je ressens
derrière derrière la question
merci Dan Daniel
Salm merci euh quelques questions un peu
techniques mais vous avez parlé
d'augmentation de de la puissance sur
certains réacteurs est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un petit peu plus sur
ces ces potentialités de combien est-ce
que l'on peut augmenter et on a été
parfois interrogé il y a eu des
questions de de mes collègues sur la
modulation de puiss aussi des réacteurs
aujourd'hui comment cela se passe avec
l'arrivée par moment d'énergie
renouvelable qui sont par nature
variable comment cela se passe sur sur
les réacteurs est-ce que l'on diminue
vraiment leur puissance quelle est la
réalité des faêites combien d'heures
quelle puissance pour bien comprendre
qui est-ce qui est à priorité sur
l'autre et comment vous vous fonctionner
à ce
niveau-là autrement vous avez parlé de
problèm potentiel pour passer la je
dirais la 5è visite décennale qui se
poserait sur neu ne réacteur est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
ces ces interrogations et pour rebondir
sur la question des la corrosion sous
contrainte qui était une panne on va
dire générique avec les atouts les
inconvénients d'avoir des réacteurs de
même
conception est-ce que dans vos
anticipations il y a d'autres panes
génériques qui pourraient survenir et et
dans ce cas-là comment est-ce que vous
les anticipez même si je comprends bien
que la la question est un peu
délicate merci on prendra une une série
après on va vous laisser répondre dans
l'ordre si c'est possible pour qu'on s'y
retrouve question de Henry Cabanel
d'abord s'il vous plaî alors je comment
dire je essayie de répondre sans rien
oublier vous me rappellerez si j'ai j'ai
loupé quelque chose les donc pour
procéder au réparation
de de nos
circuits affectés par la corrosion sous
contrainte fait l'approche a consisté à
à à découper le circuit pour remplacer
les portions dans lesquelles nous avions
des soudures qui présentaient des
défauts de corrosion sous contrainte
donc
concrètement très schématiquement on on
on coupe de part et d'autrre de la
soudure affectée et puis on remplace le
tronçon et nous avons fait le choix
d'ailleurs de faire des remplacements
euh euh toujours de la même manière ce
qui nous permettait de nous affranchir
des contrôles et et puis
d'industrialiser les les procèus de
réparation donc on a gagné du temps nous
avons fait appel à des des entreprises
euh très qualifiées parce que on
intervient sur un circuit qui est
connecté au circuit primaire et donc
avec un niveau d'exigence de qualité qui
est extrêmement élevé ces entreprises là
ont ont fait un travail de développement
euh de nouveaux procédés de soudage qui
est sont extrêmement extrêmement
intéressants et nous avons
euh à la fois gagné du temps notamment
grâce au développement de préfabrication
euh et euh euh nous avons également
développé des procédés qui sont euh euh
plus favorable euh au regard du euh
risque ultérieur de développement sous
contrainte je veux dire par là que le
procédé euh protège dans une certaine
mesure euh nous protège de l'apparition
euh dans 20 30 ans de de corrosion sous
contrainte ça pour dire que ces
entreprises là sont des entreprises du
tissu industriel français dans le
domaine nucléaire qui ont ont montré à
l'occasion de la corrosion sous
contrainte un très haut niveau de
technicité
avec l'utilisation de de de technologie
dont on ne disposait pas à la
construction qui permettent une qualité
de réalisation meilleure que la
fabrication initiale notamment en
utilisant une une modélisation 3D de
l'installation et ce qui permet
d'ajuster les montages pour arriver
pilpoil euh en face des tuyoteries
raccordé quand on fait ce ce travail euh
nous avions une charge d'activité euh
qui était euh non prévu lors de la
corosion sous contrainte qui
s'inscrivait dans un programme déjà
copieux je vous en ai parlé au début et
euh nous avions évidemment à cœur de
pouvoir réparer le plus vite possible no
réacteurs donc certains de ces
euh certaines des entreprises qui ont
été sollicité par par ODF ont fait appel
à des équipes venant de l'étranger alors
c'est le cas
de Framatome qui a fait appel à des
soudeurs nord-américains qui travaillent
dans la filiale nord-américaine de
framatou qui sont intervenus sur un
chantier sur la centrale de ch et c'est
le cas aussi de la société westing House
qui a une une filiale en France qui a
fait appel à des ressources américaines
de la maison mè si je puis dire qui sont
intervenus sur plusieurs sites et qui
sont de
l'ordre
de quelques dizaines de personnes dans
les deux cas
euh alors jeis dire la la réciproque est
vraie aussi c'estàdire que les les
entreprises de la filière nucléaire
française notamment le C Framatome
envoie aussi ses équipes à l'étranger
dans certains cas pour faire des
chantiers
euh si je puis me permettre la la la
notoriété des soudeur étranger sur
l'affaire de la corrosion sous
contrainte a été à peu près inversement
proportionnel à la quantité de travail
qu'ils ont réalisé parce que la très
très grande majorité des activités ont
été réalisées par des entreprises de la
filière nucléaire française utilisant
des ressources françaises leurs salariés
normaux c'est pas la l'activité a été
marginalement réalisé par des soudeurs
des soudeurs étrangers sur flamandville
3 et et HPC euh alors euh
je pour comment dire mon mon travail est
de m'occuper du parc existant et donc je
vais pas pouvoir vous répondre
directement ou complètement euh mais par
la suite vous allez euh auditionner des
personnes qui sont dédiées à cette ces
activités de de de nouveaux réacteurs
euh ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
nous nous bénéficions
de d'un retour d'expérience de
d'exploitation de d'un parc de
réacteur que nous mettons à profit par
une coopération avec nos collègues qui
s'occupent de concevoir des récteurs
neufs parce qu'il serait vraiment
dommage de pas profiter de cette
expérience
euh dans le passé on a eu tendance à
vivre un peu séparé mais je crois que
c'est pas vrai que chez nous ne Merant
entre le concepteur et puis l'exploitant
aujourd'hui on travaille de manière
beaucoup plus proche euh de façon à ce
que la conception bénéficie de tout ce
retour d'expérience euh pour ce qui est
du parc existant je peux vous garantir
que on est évidemment très euh mobilisé
sur la réalisation des grands travaux
qui concernent le parc et la mise en
place du grand carénage euh est aussi la
mise en place de mode de
fonctionnement nouveaux entre euh les
gens qui font fonctionner les réacteurs
et et ceux qui conçoivent en
l'occurrence les modifications et pas
des réacteurs neufs pour anticiper le
plus possible et le mieux possible ces
ces modifications de manière à ce que
lorsque la visite de scénal se présente
et bien elle se passe bien et les choses
se passent plutôt bien avec ces ces
visites décennales qui contiennent un
très grand nombre d'activités euh je
vous ai dit six fois supérieur à ce que
nous avions connu 10 ans plus tôt mais
qui se déroule dans de bonnes conditions
même même si c'est beaucoup de travail
évidemment euh mais en travaillant plus
en amont ensemble avec des méthodes de
projets nouvell nous avons réussi à
mieux anticiper les choses bon notre
pierre à l'édifice si je puux dire pour
le nouveau nucléaire c'est d'apporter
notre notre expérience de d'exploitant
de centrale à ceux qui conçoivent les
nouveaux les nouvelles installations
eu
la vous avez parlé des relations entre
l'exploitant et le régulateur dans la
crise de la corrosion sous contrainte
alors
là-dessus il y a un point qui est
extrêmement important c'est que la
responsabilité de la Sûreté Nucléaire
elle appartient à l'exploitant elle doit
être complètement incarnée et assumée
par l'exploitant donc c'est à nous de
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent
pour garantir la sûreté des
installations et ces décisions sont
soumises au contrôle et à l'avis de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire euh qui
euh le cas échéant nous euh euh demande
des actions complémentaires ou nous fait
part de de de ces désaccords et et et
c'est
une c'est une comment dire un mode de
fonctionnement euh inhérent à notre
activité que d'avoir ce dialogue avec
euh notre régulateur euh moi j'ai
travaillé pendant euh 20 ans sur des
sites
euh et et et c'est très près et je peux
vous dire que ce qui est essentiel
c'est d'assumer ce ce rôle d'exploitant
avant toute chose et de penser la sûreté
indépendamment si je puis dire de ce que
va nous demander l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire parce que cette sûreté doit
être incarné quand on commence à dire
les des choses comme l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire va nous demander c'est
pas
bon c'est c'est à nous d'avoir
l'initiative et et de de proposer des
choses qui comment dire qui seront
soumises à l'approbation ou ou pas
d'ailleurs de la SN et donc c'est ce que
nous avons fait dans la CSC nous avons
pris l'initiative de d'arrêter des
réacteurs pour procéder des contrôles
nous avons pris l'initiative de de de
proposer un programme d'investigation
qui a été présentée et challengé par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire laquelle
s'appuie sur les expertises de l'IRSN
bon l'autorité de srité nucléaire peut
nous demander des choses en plus c'est
c'est le dialogue et puis à la fin de
toute façon c'est elle qui a le dernier
mot mais c'est comme ça que
c'est qu' a fonctionné notre relation
avec laasn relation normal dans le cadre
de ce de ce problème avec toujours en
tête le fait que à tout instant
l'exploitant doit assumer
cette cette responsabilité vis-à-vis de
la Sûreté
Nucléaire concernant la la poursuite
d'exploitation du
parc on s'inscrit tout à fait dans le
temps long qu'a décrit le président de
rzuk et nous travaillons aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui mais c'est pas que
aujourd'hui nous avons déjà travaillé de
longue date en utilisant nos équipes de
Red sur les éléments
qui nous permettent d'appréhender le le
viillissement de l'installation et
notamment des composants qui sont
difficilement remplaçables vous en avez
une illustration en région parisienne
avec un sur un centre de recherche de DF
qui est situé près de Fontainebleau
Renardière où vous avez une maquette
d'enceinte de confinement maquette qui
est assez impressionnante puisqu'elle
doit faire une vingtaine de mètres de
haut et et cette maquette d'enceinte de
confinement est soumise à un traitement
un peu rude qui permet d'anticiper le
vieillissement des enceinte de
confinement de nos centrales actuelles
donc ça c'est voz ce projet là a été
conçu il y a plus de 10 ans maintenant
en en vue d'anticiper d'avoir une image
du comportement de nos enceintes à 60 70
80 ans avec une caractéristique qui est
importante et qui justifiait ce choix
c'est que pour le béton l'effet de
taille permet d'accélérer le
viillissement donc vous avez une image
du du comportement futur de de
l'installation c'est vrai aussi pour les
cuves sur lequel il y a des des des
analyses métallurgiques qui sont faites
par des prélèvements desprouvettes qui
sont placés dans les cuves qui
permettent d'avoir une image future donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui est préparé
depuis aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
que nous nous nous préparons de longues
dates avec d'abord des actions de
recherche et développement ensuite des
actions d'ingénierie plus appliqué on
parle là de programme de contrôle ou de
remplacement et puis ensuite des
programmes de contrôle sur
l'installation ce qui est nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que la
question de la poursuite d'exploitation
à 60 ans voir au-delà est ouverte alors
qu'auparavant elle ne l'était pas et si
je puis dire euh pardonnez-moi
l'expression mais on on rentre un peu
dans le dur là puisque euh nous sommes
en train de dialoguer avec l'autorité de
sité nucléaire et et elle nous a adressé
des un questionnement sur les points
précis sur lequels on doit apporter des
réponses euh et évidemment nous allons
nous appuyer sur tous les travaux qui
ont déjà été effectués sur sur ce
sujet-là euh par rapport à à l'effet
falaise finalement euh bon
le enfin faut bien considérer que la la
politique énergétique ne nous appartient
pasement nous en tant
qu'exploitant notre rôle c'est de
prendre
soin le mieux possible du parc nucléaire
et et et de le mettre en
possibilité de fonctionner le plus
longtemps possible alors ça un terme
bien évidemment de manière à ce que les
les choix puissent être faits avec
suffisamment d'anticipation pour qu'on
ne soit pas contraint d'arrêter
brutalement une grande partie de de nos
de nos installations
euh l'intégration de des opération de
démantelllement est déjà faite dans les
comment dire enfin plutôt les coûts de
démantelllement sont déjà intégrés dans
le coût les coûts de production actuel
sous forme de provision DF dispose
d'actifs dédiés euh qui serviront à
financer euh les le démantelllement des
installations en fait qui servent déjà a
financer le démantelllement des
installations puisqu'il est en cours sur
plusieurs réacteurs dont celui de Chud
centrale dite cha a dans les Ardennes et
puis évidemment celle faim donc il y a
pas d'effet
de d'un de dément du démantellement
pardon des installations et ce coup
moyen excusez-moi ce coup moyen de
production vous le chiffrez à combien
euh en en intégrant bien sûr le coup de
démantelllement et puis les
investissements à venir vous l'estimez à
combien aujourd'hui là je pas pouvoir
vous répondre parce que c'est c'est pas
mon domaine et c'est comment dire c'est
c'est une donnée qui alors en fait dans
votre question vous avez la prod de
production non c'est pas ça mais vous
m'avez dit que il y a à la fois la
production le démantelllement et et puis
les investissements futurs donc en fait
la question porte sur le modèle
économique du parc nucléaire et là en
l'occurrence pour ce qui est du modèle
économique c'est pas mon domaine de
compétence c'est pour ça que je peux pas
vous répond mais moi je parle du coût de
production de du parc existant je parle
pas du parc futur je parle parc
existant
voahà voilà oui mais vous avez bien vu
que dans le le coût de production soit
vous intégrez les les investissements à
venir ou pas donc je je préfère vous
laisser des comment dire entre les mains
de de d'autres collègues pour vous pour
répondre à cette question
là vous avez posé une question
excusez-moi
monsieur les investissements à venir ou
pas l'opération grand carénage c'est de
l'investissement à venir c'est c'estest
décidé non c'est de l'investissement sur
comment dire sur le le parc existant
donc on sait pas trop où on va c'est
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre en terme
de de de de financement des
investissements grand carénage nouveau
nucléaire et cetera non parce que la
commission d'enquête s'intéresse le cœur
du propos c'est les prix à horizon 2035
2050 ce dont on parle là correspond à
des investissements qui sont quand même
relativement bien prédéfini j'espère
quand même qu'on sait où on va en la
matière parce que ça va évidemment avoir
des des des incidence forte dans un sens
ou dans un autre sur les les prix que
vont payer les consommateurs français
donc c'est un peu ça le quand même le
cœur du sujet si on met j'essaie
d'éclaircir le la question si on met les
choses dans l' d'abord ce que paye le
consommateur français c'est pas que le
prix de la production vous avez les prix
de production d'acheminement réseau et
cetera donc sur la exactement sur la
part
euh de l'énergie proprement ditite euh
vous avez aujourd'hui un programme
d'investissement sur le parc existant
qui est autour de 4 entre 4 et 5
milliards d'euros par an hein 4
milliards d'euros euh durant la
période jusqu'à 2000 ça a commencé en
2015 un peu en dessous des 4 milliards
d'euros c'est arrivé à 4 milliards
d'euros en 2021 là actuellement on est à
4,7 milliards d'euros donc nous avons
pardon non je parle du parc existant
c'està-dire le parc existant c'est
uniquement ce qui est en en
fonctionnement donc ce sont les ce sont
les 56
réacteurs oui existant je veux dire en
service flamandville n'est pas en
service hein c'est pour ça il y a pas
flamandville et donc le grand carénage
c'est le projet qui permet de de piloter
l'ensemble des des des activités
euh de maintenance exceptionnelle de
modification sur le parc en service et
donc le le la totalité de ces
investissements c'est 4,7 milliards
d'euros par an et et c'est assez stable
euh durant la dizaine d'années qui est
devant nous puisque nous
avons plusieurs cycles de visites
décennales qui vont succéder les les
visites décennales euh sur les réacteurs
de 900 MW puis sur les réacteurs de 1300
MW donc tout cela je vous rassure c'est
parfaitement prévu
planifier les sur le plan technique
comme sur le plan financier là où le le
modèle économique de la production
intègre d'autres éléments ça c'est ce
qui concerne le nucléaire neu c'est des
nouveaux moyens de production où le
sujet est pas encore tranché c'est pour
ça que je je je ne peux pas vous
répondre sur ce point
précis vous avez parlé d'augmentation
depu puissance donc il faut distinguer
deux deux manières d'augmenter la
puissance et en l'occurrence elle
s'applique différemment sur deux types
de réacteurs sur le réacteur de 900 MW
nous avons une possibilité d'augmenter
la puissance en changeant le une partie
du groupe turboalternateur qui est le
le la turbine à vapeur qui sert à à
entraîner l'alternateur et il y a
aujourd'hui des
technologies de turbin plus élaborées
que celles qui ont été utilisées à
origine sur une partie du parc qui
permet simplement par une augmentation
du rendement de de la turbine
d'augmenter sa puissance mécanique et
donc la puissance électrique en sortie
de l'alterateur donc vous remplacez une
partie de la turbine à vapeur vous ne
touchez à rien au réacteur vous avez un
meilleur rendement et on peut gagner sur
un réacteur de M de 900 MW pardon aux
alentours de 35 à 40 mW donc ce qui est
loin d'être négligeable plus pardon en
plus un complément de St oui absolument
tout à fait ça se fait sans
l'autorisation
alors en l'occurrence il y AP de quoi en
l'occurrence sur cette sur cette cette
modification précisément il y a pas de
euh de demande d'autorisation à
l'autorité de sûrté nucléaire parce que
ça ne modifie absolument pas les
paramètres de fonctionnement du
réacteuréeur et bien c'est parce que
euh la euh PPE a euh mis en perspective
une fermeture des réacteurs de 900 MW et
dans la mesure où ces réacteurs devaient
fermer et bien il y avait plus d'intérêt
à poursuivre c'est alors nous avons
réouvert le dossier et
et nous nous avons réouvert le dossier
pour envisager une reprise de ces
modifications sur les neu neuf tracteurs
qui sont éligibles à cette augmentation
de puissance après il faut que
économiquement le le l'augmentation de
puissance est une pertinence et puis il
y a une augmentation de puissance sur
les réacteurs de 1300 MW qui avait été
étudié dans le passé qui avait été
stoppé puisque la loi prévoyait un
plafonnement de la puissance nucléaire
installée donc on peut plus augmenter la
puissance là c'est plus compliqué parce
que si on augmente la puissance du
réacteur on modifie ses paramètres de
fonctionnement et là pour le coup c'est
un dossier qui est soumis à
l'approbation d'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire c'est plus complexe ça
permettrait d'augmenter de l'ordre de 80
MW la puissance d'un réacteur de 1300
MW
j'ai bien compris le développement
malgré cette augmentation de
puissance turbine chaudier alternateur
vous n'obtiendrez pas avant
2025 les 400
oui j'ai parlé de l'amation fa avec ça
j'ai parlé d'un horizon 2030 parce que
ces augmentation de puissance sont des
travaux qui sont lourds
et c'est pas avant plusieurs années on
peut pas les improviser il faut acheter
des approvisionnements et cetera pour le
1300 MW c'est encore plus long puisque
il faut faire des études de sûreté très
complexes euh et donc ça n'est pas tout
de suite effectivement euh vous avez
parlé de la
modulation donc le le en fait la la
modulation a a toujours existé sur le
parc et alors c'est une spécificité du
parc français so dit en passant beaucoup
d'exploitants nous l'envie
euh c'est une spécificité du parc
français parce que comme on a visé très
tôt une part de production nucléaire
importante euh le besoin de faire varier
la puissance des réacteur est apparu
très tôt puisqu'il fallait suivre euh
les variations de consommation donc les
réacteurs nucléaires sont capables de
euh varier autour d'un point de consigne
de faire varier leur puissance de
manière extrêmement euh souple avec plus
ou moins 35 MW pour un réacteur de 900
MW plus ou moins 50 MW pour un réacteur
de 1300 MW ils sont aussi capables de
baisser euh et de remonter la puissance
euh de manière euh plus importante
c'est-à-dire passer de 900 MW jusqu'à
une centaine de mgaw en en en quelques
minutes et ceci deux fois par jour
jusqu'à excusez-moi de rentrer un peu
dans le détail 90 % de l'épuisement du
combustible ça veut dire que durant 90 %
de la durée de fonctionnement entre deux
arrêts un récteur a cette aptitude à
faire deux baisses de charges qu'on
appelle profonde par jour alors c'est
cette modulation a toujours une
pertinence économique et béficie au
consommateurs puisque ça permet en
lorsqu'elle est réalisée en fait c'est
pour
permettre soit de tout simplement de de
de diminuer la puissance électrique mise
sur le réseau et parfois aussi de
laisser la place à des moyens de
production moins chers que le parc
nucléaire qui peuvent être disponibles à
un moment donné si vous avez par exemple
énormément de production éolienne à un
instant donné ben cette production est
mise sur le marché un prix très bas et
donc on efface de la puissance nucléaire
ce qui est nouveau c'est que avant on
s'adaptait à
la comment dire aux variations aux
fluctuations de la consommation
maintenant il y a la la fois une
adaptation aux fluctuations de la
consommation et puis une adaptation aux
fluctuations de la production des
énergies intermittantes donc ça fait un
peu plus de fluctuation et nous avons
nous veillons à à
conserver en permanence cette aptitude
de nos réacteurs à faire du suivi de
charge des variations de charge il y a
des périodes où on peut pas parce qu'il
faut faire des essais qui nécessite une
stabilité et cetera il y a parfois des
problèmes techniques qui l'empêchent
c'est un point qui a regardé de de très
très près et bien nous nous avons adapté
notre mode de fonctionnement et
aujourd'hui nous nous répondons présent
à cette cette modulation mais elle n'est
pas nouvelle ce qui est nouveau
c'est son caractère plus imprévisible
qu'avant puisqueavant la consommation
malgré tout il y a toujours un hiver un
été euh maintenant indépendamment de la
saison vous pouvez avoir des variations
plus importantes liées à la la aux aléas
des énergies renouvelables
intermittentes excusez-moi sur ce point
de la modulation plus plus il y a
d'énergie renouvelable non pilotable sur
sur le réseau plus plus la
modulation nucléaire
euh est nécessaire est mise en œuvre ça
ça ça n'affecte pas le le le le cycle de
de fonctionnement des des réacteurs
nucléaire ça suppose pas voilà en terme
du du du déclassement de d'une certaine
manière peut-être plus plus
important voir des investissements
nécessaires pour justement absorber ces
ces ces modulations est-ce que ça
affecte le le le cycle de fonctionnement
du réacteur lui-même la profondeur de
modulation il y a plusieurs aspects
alors en rapport avec le mix la la
composition du mix euh finalement votre
question c'est est-ce que ça sollicite
le matériel oui pu que voilà alors je
dirais que tant que on réalise des des
baisses de puissance puis enfin des
variations de puissance
sans déconnecter l'installation du
réseau pour la mettre totalement à
l'arrêt
euh il y a très peu d'effets à va dire
on a fait beaucoup d'études en la
matière pour on est même allé jusqu'à
une période placer des tranches en
fonctionnement en base c'est tout le
temps à puissance maximum pour les
comparer avec d'autres on na pas mis en
évidence d'effets euh notable sur la
fiabilité des équipements ou l'usure des
équipements ce qui est plus
problématique c'est de devoir s'arrêter
totalement pendant 24 48 he parce que
les opérations de redémarrage sont des
opérations complexes au cours desquels
vous pouvez avoir l'apparition de de
d'aléa techniqu euh qui là sont plus
problématiques tout simplement parce que
lorsque vous arrêtez complètement ben le
matériel refroidit vous avez euh les
phénomènes de dilatation de de les les
inststallation on bouge un peu et vous
pouvez avoir notamment dans la partie
conventionnelle de l'installation salle
des machines une fite de vapeur ou des
choses comme ça donc si on en reste à
des variations de puissance pas d'effet
si on doit s'arrêter puis redémarrer
s'arrêter puis redémarrer là par contre
c'est plus problématique donc on évite
de le faire et en fait on a d'autant
moins à le faire qu'on a beaucoup de
réacteurs qui sont capables de moduler
leur puissance donc c'est c'est vraiment
ça à quoi on
s'attache
je laisse passer je voulais vous
proposer d'apporter quelques éléments
complémentaires de réponse aux questions
qui ont été je sais pas si on a répondu
à toutes les questions qui ont été
posées sur les questions qui viennent
d'être posées si vous si vous le
souhaitez j'ai quelques éléments
complémentaires euh pour revenir sur la
question sur les sur les compétences et
sur les soudeurs bon Étienne dutille l'a
dit tous les soudeurs n'étaient pas
français beaucoup l'ont été je voudrais
attirer l'attention sur un sur un sur un
enjeu euh lié à ça c'est que je disais
tout à l'heure on a une filière qui est
autonome qui est complète ça veut pas
dire que l'ambition est de faire une
filière en autarcie et plus on est
autonome et plus on est capable de se
connecter je dirais à nos à nos
partenaires à nos homologues
étrangers et et à s'ouvrir non seulement
à des opportunités d'export on regarde
souvent les relations international à
travers des opportunités d'export mais
en réalité aussi a des opportunités
d'accéder à des ressources
complémentaires ponctuellement quand on
est sur des pics de charge comme ça a
été le cas là de manière à ne pas
dimensionner toute industrie sur sur le
sur le pic donc c'est c'est assez
illustratif de ce que peut faire une une
filière autonome dans sa capacité à
coopérer et plus elle est autonome plus
elle est performante plus elle est
attractive et plus elle est intéressante
pour ses partenaires et plus elle
souffre ce genre d'opportunité deuxième
point je reste sur les sur les
compétences vous parliez tout à l'heure
des soudeurs des chaudronniers et est-ce
qu'on est capable de les attirer alors
très clairement la filière voit
aujourd'hui un regain d'attractivité un
regain de candidature dans l'ensemble
des métiers il y a beaucoup plus de
candidats aujourd aujourd'hui qui a
quelques années la perspective la
dynamique qui est donnée à la filière
est le est de loin le premier facteur
qui qui apporte cette cet effet là donc
la visibilité sur la relance du
nucléaire est évidemment un facteur très
important je voudrais attirer votre
attention sur sur deux enjeux
complémentaires un enjeu qui finalement
est très sociétal on parlait des
chaudronniers des soudeurs tout à
l'heure ça veut dire des formations euh
qui vont pas jusqu'à ingénieur des
formations de Bac pro ou des formations
en bac+ 3 euh on a un véritable enjeu
sociétal je dire tous ensemble à
valoriser ces formations et à faire en
sorte que bah tous les jeunes n'aient
pas forcément envie parce qu'ils sont
bons à l'école d'aller jusqu'à un bac +
5 ou un bac + 12 mais à à estce qu'on
vraiment valorise ces métiers ces
métiers techniques euh et qui font n nos
soudeur d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
vous voyez bien que c'est pas un sujet
purement nucléaire en fait en réalité
c'est un sujet industriel et c'est c'est
là où la dynamique de relance du
nucléaire peut jouer un rôle beaucoup
plus large que que ça dans la
réindustrialisation c'est aussi un enjeu
je vrais le connecter est ce que je
parlais tout à l'heure de
performance la performance est un al ce
que je vais appeler la performance c'est
le fait que le soudeur passe plus de
temps à souder qu'à attendre ou qu'à
faire des procédures qu'à faire toutes
ces chosesl en fait hein euh c'est un
enjeu d'attractivité mais c'est aussi
presque surtout un enjeu de fidélisation
et un enjeu de d'optimisation de
l'exploitation de la ressource
évidemment on réduit la la pression sur
les besoins en nombre de soudeurs si on
fait en sorte qu'il soude davantage donc
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille sur les
deux leviers que j'ai j'évoqué tout à
l'heure euh vous demandiez madame la
signatrice si on était en
mesuréite d'apporter des gages de
sérieux à l'état suite au aux
expériences connues à Flamanville ouou
en ce moment à à Inle point
alors je renvoie surtout aux
enseignements qu'on tire de ces ce
projet là et pour aller sur une notion
qui me semble absolument fondamentale
c'est que la performance est le résultat
de la mobilisation industrielle et le
résultat de la dynamique
industrielle flamville n'a pas été
réalisé dans le cadre d'une dynamique
industrielle c'est un projet
isolé et il a été l'objet de de
justement de la reconstitution
d'expérience d'enseignement et je vous
renvoie au au rapport false de 2019 qui
pour la filière collectivement est
absolument fondamental et depuis 2019 et
depuis ce rapport nous avons
collectivement il a été fait référence
au plan Excel tout à l'heure qui a
mobilisé vraiment toute la filière donc
ça fait maintenant 4 5 ans que l'on
travaille sur la base de ces
enseignements euh sur les différents
axes de de performance euh évidemment le
projet Inle point en Angleterre est le
premier sur lequel on met en œuvre c'est
cette dynamique d'amélioration dans un
contexte qui par ailleurs euh la
réalisation d'un d'un projet d'un projet
nucléaire a une une grande dimension
locale donc on est dans le contexte en
Angleterre à nouveau d'une tête de série
euh et d'un contexte de redéveloppement
d'une industrie nucléaire pour presque
dire une industrie tout cours euh qui
qui qui fait qu'on est sur un un un
chemin vous n'avez pas cité un troisième
projet qui était celui en Chine qui dans
la dans la même enfin dans la dynamique
industrielle que j'évoquais c'est pour
le coup très bien passé euh et donc ça
ça montre à quel point le contexte et la
perspective et la dynamique industrielle
sont absolument fondamentaux je dis ça
parce que c'est c'est l'engagement de
cette dynamique qui est en cours en
France et dans laquelle on est dans une
phase de de préparation de mobilisation
et avec tout l'engagement que vous vous
pouvez
imaginer que le principal enjeu
est sans sans
aucune réserve et et et sans sans aucune
patience aller sur la conformité
immédiate et la performance doit se
construire à travers le lancement de ce
de ce nouveau de ce nouveau programme
d'ailleurs je finis avec ça
l'exemple a été donné par Étienne
lutille tout à l'heure sur les chantiers
CSC qui comme l'a dit Étienne ont
beaucoup progresser d'une réalisation à
l'autre c'est l'application concrète de
cette de cette dynamique quand elle est
pilotée monsieur dosuc je passer la
parole à
Jean-Jacques répond aux questions qui
qui on été posé peut-être et auquell
Monsieur D n'a pas répondu parce que ce
n'était pas son son domaine bon tout
d'abord la question la surtransposition
je crois que on n'est pas du tout dans
un cas comparable parce qu' il n'y a pas
dans le domaine du nucléaire de
réglementation internationale il y a pas
d'harbonisation donc on surtranspose
quand on est conduit à à appliquer en
droit national quelque chose qui a été
décidé collectivement au niveau
international que ça soit au niveau
communautaire à l'Europe au niveau
international par la ua ce n'est pas le
cas nous sommes souverains dans chaque
pays du monde nous sommes souverains sur
l'élaboration de notre niveau d'exigence
de notre niveau de contrôle et nous
considérons tous je crois que ça c'est
vraiment il y a pas de de divergence
là-dessus que la la confiance dans le
contrôle de la sûreté dans le niveau
d'exigence est un bien commun que nous
devons préserver je pense qu'il n'y a
pas de développement nucléaire s'il n'y
a pas de confiance dans le niveau de
sûreté et dans le contrôle de la sûreté
donc nous ne sommes pas dans un cas de
surtransposition nous définissons
nous-mêmees le niveau qui nous semble
adéquat pour que cette confiance existe
dans le contrôle ça veut pas dire que un
accident est pas possible dans le
contrôle je deuxième point la relation
entre EDF
ASN et en complément IRSN sur la
corrosion sous contrainte monsieur dal a
parfaitement décrit la manière dont les
choses se sont dérouléesin l'exploitant
nucléaire EDF a totalement assurer sa
responsabilité première c'est lui qui
devant les découvertes qu'il a fait lui
a décidé les mesure à prendre la mise à
l'arrêt de certains réacteurs la la
prolongation des arrêts des réacteurs
qui é actuel pour aller voir sur un
échantillon représentatif du parc on est
dans un parc générique avec un risque
générique un parc standardisé pardon au
moment où la découverte se fait
l'exploitant ne sait pas où ce où sont
ces corrosions pourquoi elles sont et
quelle est la taille et donc il prend
une décision extrêmement responsable de
dire je vais aller voir un échantillon
représentatif une quinzaine de réacteurs
qui je vais le mettre à l'arrêt soit je
vais prolonger les arrêts parce que
certains à l'arrêt et je vais aller voir
les mêmes circuits pour savoir ce qui se
passe et c'est à partir de ce moment-là
qu'il peut fournir des éléments de
stratégie et c'est il nous la soumet et
c'est nous qui l'approuvons après
bienant sur certains points avoir
demandé à lirsn de nous donner son avis
mais ça s'est passé comme ça et je pense
que c'est bien que ça se soit passé
comme ça et donc ce n'est pas une
impulsion extérieure c'est pas un tiers
extérieur qui a poussé EDF à le faire
c'est EDF qui l'a fait
la question que vous posez sur le
dilemme je prends ce terme éventuel par
rapport à ce que je disais sur
effectivement l'effet palier
et point important de ne pas considérer
que la poursuite d'exploitation est une
variable d'ajustement bien évidemment
nous n'avons qu'une seule mission en
tant qu'n contrairement à ce que
j'entends notre seule mission c'est
de la protection pardon des personnes et
de l'environnement nous n'avons pas de
mission en tant qu'autorité indépendante
à faire des arbitrages on fait pas
d'arbitrage entre la sûreté et puis la
sécurité d'alimentation électrique notre
seule mission qui nous a été confié par
la loi c'est de nous prononcer sur la
sûreté et donc si il s'avérait que que
ça soit d'ailleurs sur un un parc dans
dans futur en futur en terme
d'exploitation jusqu'à 60 ans au-delà ou
même aujourd'hui si nous avions intime
conviction qu'il y a un problème de
sûreté notre responsabilité ça serait de
le dire et de le dire d'abord au
gouvernement la loi prévoit que dans ce
cas c'est le gouvernement qui décide et
puis si il y a un risque imminent c'est
à nous à décider tout de suite sans même
laave du gouvernement et ben ça c'est
notre mission et donc je je dis que
voilà on n pas d'arbitrage à faire ne
mélangons pas les choses la SN n'est pas
une autorité de sûreté qui
fait un espèce de balance une espèce de
balance entre la l'approvisionnement
électrique et la sûreté non sa seule
mission c'est la sûreté c'est dans la
loi
et enfin la question des neuf réacteurs
donc les neuf réacteurs que nous avons
identifiés dans notre avis de de juin
2023 ce sont d'abord cinq réacteurs qui
sont des réacteurs qui ont des coudes
moulé qui sont fixés sur la cuve du
réacteur et ces coups de moulé sont
susceptibles de ne pas pouvoir vieillir
ils sont il y a des effet température
des effets d'exposition au neutrons qui
fait que le métal s'affaiblit et
sur ces coups de Moulet nous avons
besoin d'avoir des garanties
supplémentaires que ils peuvent
effectivement tenir au-delà de 50 ans
euh pour pouvoir aller de 50 à 60 ans
donc ils sont très clairement identifiés
les neuf réacteurs sont cités les les
cinq réacteurs sont cités et à ces cinq
réacteurs s'ajoutent les quatre
réacteurs de cruass hein du fait que ce
cette centrale est proche d' d'une
faille lié au séisme du Tail pour lequel
il est nécessaire de faire des
investigations complémentaires pour
s'assurer qu'il ne peut pas y avoir des
effets de décrochement en surface si
cette faille redevenait active donc
c'est ce sont les neuf réacteurs qui
sont dans notre
décision voilà merci je donne la parole
à Jean-Jacques merillou et à Stéphane
piénoir qui l'a demandé également
oui merci merci Monsieur j'ai deux
questions la la première quand le
président de la République dans son
discours de Belfort a décidé de relancer
la filière nucléaire toutes les
auditions que nous avons eu ensuite parl
de la de la difficulté qu'il y aurait à
trouver suffisamment de de main d'œuvre
pour relancer cette filière donc
monsieur Bard vous avez dit que vous
étudiez cette question là si j'ai bien
compris que vous et donc aujourd'hui où
est-ce qu'on en est alors pour
aujourd'hui mais aussi pour pour les
années à venir et ensuite monsieur le
Président de laasn dans votre discours
liminaire vous avez parlé donc de
d'anticipation en particulier sur la
filière aval et vous avez vous avez
juste dit quelques mots alors c'est vrai
qu'on qu'on se soucie beaucoup de la
production et peut-être pas assez de ça
donc pouvez-vous nous à dire un petit
peu plus pour sur cette commission
d'enquête quels sont les points de
vigilance et les tant technique que
qu'économique puisqu'on est aussi
sur le prix de l'électricité futur
merci cétait c'était on on va donner la
parole à Stéphane
pinoir merci monsieur le Président merci
messieur pour vos vos réponses très
précises on va dans le détail c'est bien
de ce qu'on attend de cette commission
d'enquête euh je vais avoir deux
questions mais qui se rejoignent sur
finalement le le modèle économique de de
production et du du coût de
l'électricité puisque c'est c'est
l'objet de de de nos travaux euh vous
avez dit tout à l'heure on a beaucoup
parlé de la de l'effet falaise mais une
falaise ça se descend on évoque les les
les réacteurs qui ont été construits euh
quasiment tous en même temps sur la même
période d'une quinzaine d'années environ
mais une palaise une falaise ça se ça se
grimpe aussi et euh je je dis ça parce
que il y a visiblement une politique
dans ce pays qui vise à électrifier euh
bon nombre de pans de notre société on
pense bien sûr aux ventes de véhicules
électriques on est quasiment à à un/4
des des des ventes aujourd'hui qui sont
électriques ou hybrides mais aussi dans
le bâtiment et je pense à la re 2020 qui
était déjà un sujet derrière nous mais
avec des décrets qui visent à
aujourd'hui ne pas pouvoir remplacer les
chaudières à gaz lorsqu'elles tombent en
panne mais à mettre à la place une pompe
à chaleur en Amot donc est-ce que vous
avez un dialogue avec l'exécutif euh
au-delà du du discours de Belfort qui
vise à mettre en en concordance les
objectifs d'électrification de notre
société de notre
ouais de notre société l'ensemble de
notre de nos usages et la production en
face l'augmentation de la production et
et les moyens d'y faire face donc c'est
est-ce que ce lissage est-ce que vous
avez un dialogue sur sur le lissage de
cette production et puis la deuxième
question c'est j'ai entendu parler tout
à l'heure de de périodes pendant
lesquelles on était amené à moduler les
la production en baissant la production
dans les réacteurs tout ça évidemment va
monter en puissance si on peut dire avec
la production d'énergie renouvelable
intermittente ou non pilotable comme
vous voudrez est-ce qu'il y a une
opportunité de profiter de cette
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire pour stocker l'énergie euh je
je veux évidemment viser la production
d'hydrogène sur les périodes fastes de
production qui pourrait ensuite être
réutilisé on connaît évidemment les les
pertes et le coefficient euh
relativement faible sur sur ce type de
de processus mais néanmoins est-ce qu'il
y a une étude de de de marché si je peux
dire sur cette production d'hydrogène
dans les périodes de de production ou de
surproduction d'électricité dans notre
pays on aura des des auditions
spécifiques sur les notamment la
dernière question Henri Cabanel m'a
demandé la parole également oui
excusez-moi juste une un complément
d'information pour ce qui me concerne le
le le coûte le coûte de fonctionnement
d'une centrale nucléaire en pleine
production est-il le même que le coûte
d'une centrale qui serait donc
euh à à une production limitée ça
voudrait si oui si la réponse est oui ça
voudrait dire que le le prix de revient
du kilwh d'une centrale en pleine
production est inférieur donc à le prix
de revien d'une centrale qui ne
fonctionne pas en pleine
production mes collègues voit la fin de
l'audition se profiler alors demande t
la parole Daniel oui juste pour creuser
encore ce sujet là qui est qui me semble
très important lorsque on fait une
modulation de puissance donc qu'on la
diminue il y a sans doute je pense
également une
diminution de consommation de
combustible et donc c'est tout sur toute
la filière qui a un impact puisque qui
dit moins moins de combustible dit moins
moins de déchets Infiné donc je voilà
est-ce que tout cela est pour répondre
vraiment aux questions de savoir le
mgawh son prix il faut avoir tout cela
en vision donc je je pense que c'est
c'est pas inintéressant euh sur le
démantèlement juste euh vous a dit que
c'était provisionné par contre à combien
parce que je crois queentre les
provisions qui sont faites en France
pour le démantelllement d'un réacteur et
les provisions qui sont faite en
Allemagne il y a un facteur 3 qu
peut-être plus donc si vous pouvez nous
dire un petit peu ce qu'il en est à ce
sujet et l'utre c'est juste une petite
remarque il me semblait que le Pr de
flamandville était dans une certaine
dynamique ça devait être une tête de
pont une tête de série pour et bien un
développement de la filière nucléaire
dans le monde entier donc je pense qu'on
était dans une certaine dynamique mais
qui a eu quelques quelques
accros dernière question en écho à la à
la remarque de Monsieur dorozuk sur le
l'anticipation de l'effet falaise euh
vous en appelez un une planification et
énergétique robuste c'est ce sont vos
mots est-ce que l'étude RTE future
énergétique 2050 prend en compte comme
cela est souhaitable en terme
d'anticipation les fait falaisees dont
on a discuter où est-ce qu'il faudrait
aller au-delà la prolonger vous avez la
parole pour répondre à ces questions et
euh et monsieur le rapporteur non
mais monsieur le Président moi moi j'ai
j'ai déjà posé des questions j'en aurai
d'autres mais on va pas prolonger non
plus il y en a qui ont été posés
simplement on aura des questionnaires
qu'on va vous envoyer et dans lesquels
il y aura sans doute des questions
complémentaires ou des choses qu'on a
pas pu poser là donc je pense que le
mieux c'est c'est quand même que vous
répondiez là assz rapidement au aux
questions qui viennent d'être posées et
puis ensuite je pense qu'il sera bon de
de conclure effectivement allez vous
avez la parole monsieur
dut j'ai commencé par le les provisions
pour démantellement donc là-dessus aussi
on peut vous fournir tous les éléments
que vous souhaitez soullignez que le
fait que c ces provisions sont pas c'est
pas l'initiative de DF ils sont
contrôler très régulièrement et et je
sais que parfois on est comparé au au
comment dire à ce qui se passe en
Alemagne faut savoir que en France les
provisions font l'objet d'actifs dédiés
qui qui sont vraiment en Allemagne une
grande partie de la provision c'est la
valaleur de l'entreprise
elle-même qui dans une sorte de
sacrifice final finance le
démantellement de ses installations il y
a pas d'actif dédiés donc les chiffres
peuvent être différents derrière la
réalité économique euh et et également
très
différente les actifs dédiés de DF pour
le démantèlement sont euh vraiment des
choses qui sont mobilisables pour payer
ce ce démantellement et qui font l'objet
encore une fois de de ce contrôle euh
votre question sur la modulation
l'utilisation de l'énergie est
extrêmement intéressante en fait il faut
savoir que un réacteur nucléaire c'est
un réservoir d'énergie en fait c'est un
stock et donc ce ce stock d'énergie qui
physiquement correspond à l'uranium que
vous avez mis au combustible que vous
avez mis dans le réacteur au pendant le
le
rechargement vous donne un potentiel de
production
euh qui peut être utilisé soit en
fonctionnement en fonctionnement en
permanence à pleine puissance soit en
fonctionnant plus longtemps mais en
modulant la puissance mais dans tous les
cas la même quantité d'énergie va être
utilisée donc la modulation n'est pas
une diminution en
fait de l'utilisation du potentiel
énergétique de la centrale puisque quoi
qu'il arrive à la fin vous avez épuisé
c'est le terme qu'on utilise consommer
le réservoir d'énergie par contre la
modulation permet de placer l'énergie au
bon moment et et je vous disais que
parfois on a un afflux de production
important de de de d'éolien parce que il
y a beaucoup de vent il y a également
les pics du solaire qui commence à se
faire sentir c'est intéressant de
pouvoir s'effacer à cet endroit-là pour
laisser la place à une électricité
fatale qui peut être à certain moment
moins chè et ensuite du coup le le coût
de fonctionnement d'une centrale en fait
n'est pas différent
euh si vous fonctionnez en base si vous
faites des variations de charge puisque
en fait une centrale c'est essenellement
des coûts fixes et et comme on l'a vu
tout à l'heure le le mode de
fonctionnement avec modulation n'induit
pas euh des volumes de maintenance
significatifs en plus le coût est le
même par contre l'énergie produite sera
toujours la même vous voyez par contre
le le économiquement le placement de
l'énergie est plus intéressant si vous
pouvez faire si vous pouvez faire de la
modulation je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est une pratique que l'on a couramment
sur notre parc et d'autres commencent à
nous regarder parce que vous avez des
exploitants étrangers qui fonctionner
tout le temps en base et et
l'introduction des énergies
renouvelables intermittentes dans les
réseaux fait que euh il y a des moments
où ils aimeraient bien s'effacer et il
faut qu'ils acquierent cette capacité à
faire de la la
modulation alors aujourd'hui par rapport
à votre question sur le
stockage il n'y a pas de
moyen
industriel de stocker l'énergie dans
grande
quantité finalement ce qu'on sait faire
de mieux pour le stockage de l'énergie
c'est les step les stations
deénergie hydraulique qu'on qu'on qu'on
vient stocker le reste les batteries et
cetera ça reste extrêmement marginal par
rapport au au au à la puissance appelée
sur sur un réseau électrique peut-être
que l'hydrogène sera une une réponse
plus tard faut avoir en tête que les
tout de même les les électrolyseurs sont
des des appareils qui fonctionnent
plutôt en continu donc il est pas
certain que ça euh réponde au au besoin
de stockage je voudrais juste par contre
souligner qu'on a à travers les
interconnexions une possibilité
de d'écouler la production dont on n pas
besoin d' instant donné si elle trouve
preneur sur le marché vous savez que
durant le l'hiver dernier on a battu à
deux reprises notre record de
d'exportation parce que fin décembre on
a exporté une puissance qui en une
production de qui correspond à une
puissance de 20 GW ça veut dire que
concrètement vous avez une quinzaine de
réacteurs qui fonctionnait uniquement
pour l'exportation donc ce qui est
évidemment une bonne chose mais
aujourd'hui il y a pas de solution de
stockage et on peut pas dire qu'il y a
une solution industrielle de stockage
qui se comment dire qui
se se prépare si
dessine pour ce qui est de de l'effet
falaise à la hausse avec développement
de la consommation l'électrification des
usages saz qu'aujourd'hui on le voit pas
encore puisque
la la sobriété énergétique fait qu'on
est plutôt
depuis un ou de ans sur une baisse de la
cons consommation cela étant on anticipe
effectivement à travers
l'électrification des usages une
augmentation de la production
euh comment dire la la vision globale
est est vous êtes donné par le RTE qui
qui a la vision de tous les producteurs
parce qu'il y a pas c DF et évidemment
de tous les moyens de les moyens de de
production puisqu'il y a pas que le
nucléaire
euh ce que je peux vous dire mais c'est
extrêmement euh
extrêmement global hein c'est que nous
avons besoin
pour décarboner l'économie et
électrifier les usages bon ce qui n'a
l'électrification n'a d'intérêt au
regard de la décarbonation que si les
moyens de comment dire de de production
sont décarboné hein quand vous utilisez
une voiture électrique en Allemagne elle
fonctionne au charbon si je fais court
bon pour faire ça on a besoin de tous
les moyens de production décarbonés et
donc on a besoin du nucléaire on a
besoin aussi des énergies renouvelable
euh il y a pas aujourd'hui de de vision
d'impossibilité euh de répondre à ces
besoins croissant à partir du moment où
on développe l'ensemble des moyens de
production et où on nppose pas euh les
moyens de production décarbonés les uns
aux autres voilà je pense avoir à peu
près fait le tour Monsieur D merci
Monsieur moi je voudrais répondre à deux
questions tiellement la l'aval du cycle
et puis le votre question sur la sur RTE
alors le le choix fait en France de de
mettre en place un un retraitement des
combustibles usé à travers le choix donc
de la Val du cycle est un choix de
politique industrielle et et la question
qui se pose par rapport à au sujet
d'anticipation que j'aiévoqué est à à
deux niveaux j'ai évoqué le court terme
qui est celui de de la sécurisation je
le mets entre guillemets de du
fonctionnement des installations
actuelles jusqu'à horizon 2040 2050 ça
c'est on maintient le dispositif pour
des raisons de souveraineté de réduction
du du volume de déchets ultimes c'est la
tendance sur laquelle nous sommes la
politique sur laquelle nous sommes et là
il faut absolument sécuriser
l'installation de production du MOX
c'est-à-dire l'usine Melox qui connaî
qui n'a pas connu niveau de performance
satisfaisant ces dernières années et il
faut vraisemblablement pour l'orison
2040- 2050 envisager une nouvelle us MOX
qui pourra
assurer la poursuite de du retraitement
si celui-ci est décidé donc ça c'est un
sujet important il y a un sujet de
dérisquage des installations de la hag
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il y a y a deux
unités de retraitement qui sont l'up2800
et UP3 et ce sont des lignes qui sont
totalement en silo elles ne sont pas
interconnecté et donc s'il y a un organe
une partie de la ligne qui est
défaillante on ne peut pas réorienter
l'utre dérisage à faire ça c'est
toujours dans TER de
sécurisation il y a un certain nombre de
PO je pense
NOTAM au PO de
dissolution qui sont pas dédoubl
uni c'est un al qui bloque la totalité
de l'usine donc il faut aussi sécuriser
ses postes il y a la question de la
saturation des des combustibles usés
avec euh le projet de de piscine
centralisée et qui arrivera
visemblablement peut-être plus tard qui
pourrait arriver plus tard que la
saturation des piscines actuelles et
donc il faut mettre en place une parade
pour pouvoir tenir et
ano a proposé de densifier les piscine
actuelle c'està-dire de mettre davantage
de combustible usé dans les piscine
actuelle comme étant une parade qui
permet d'attendre la disponibilité de la
piscine nouvelle euh donc donc il y a
tout ça c'est ça qu' faut anti et tout
ça ça prend du temps il faut faire des
études il faut faire des constructions
c'est c'est extrêmement long alors
ensuite il y a un deuxième niveau
d'anticipation c'est après 2040
2050 si si ça va bien jusque là après il
faut décider qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire
et là il y a un premier choix à faire
est-ce que l'on poursuitite le
retraitement ou est-ce qu'on arrête le
retraitement il y a pas beaucoup de pays
dans le monde qui retraitentin mais
c'est a un vrai choix politique
si il était décidé politiquement de ne
pas poursuivre le retraitement et ben il
faut anticiper de d'une quinzaine
d'années le fait qu'à partir de
l'horizon 2040 2050 il y aura des
combustibles usés il faut bien les
mettre quelque part d' c ça n'arrête pas
le parc mais il y a toujours des
combustibles usés et donc il faut
envisager des solutions alternatives
notamment ce qui se fait à l'étranger
l'entreposage à sec pour avoir des
capacité d'entreposage à sec des
combustibles usés en France il faut 10 à
15 ans d'anticipation donc il faut
décider ce qu'on fait et si on prend
cette ce choix il faut anticiper les
conséquences de ce choix s'il était
décidé de poursuivre le retraitement il
faut définir de manière une vision
stratégique quel type de retraitement
aujourd'hui les usines de la Hague ne
font que du monoretraitement on fait
qu'une seule fois le retraitement et on
on entrepose du MOX usé c'est ça qui
conduit à la saturation des piscines
est-ce que on on on ambition de faire du
multiretraitement c'est dire de
réutiliser le moxusé c'est c'est une
option ou pas hein donc voyez-vous il y
a un certain nombre de questions qu'il
faut se poser parce que les choix sur la
future installation dépendront de ce qui
est fait aujourd'hui on a une série de
combustibles usés qui ne sont pas
valorisés ce sont les combustibles dit
particuliers les combustible Phénix usé
des combustibles usés de super Phénix et
des combustibles usés de
militaire ils sont entreposés parce que
on pense qu'on c'est possible de les
valoriser c'est vrai mais on n pas les
installations pour le faire l'usine de
la ne peut pas valoriser ses
combustibles donc si on veut les
valoriser il faut que dans la future
usine qui sera décidé il y a une une
chaîne qui permettra enfin une ligne qui
permettra de valoriser ces combustibles
particuliers et et plus on voudra faire
de choses avec la future usine et plus
il faudra
et donc être certain du des procédés qui
ne seront pas les mêmes que ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui en place sur l'usine de
lac pour la future uside donc ça suppose
des des un temps de recherche de
développement de prototype ça prend du
temps tout ça voilà illustrer si vous
voulez en terme d'anticipation ce qu'il
faut faire c'est au cœur des décisions
qui sont àprend en terme de politique
énergétique dans les dans les 2 ans qui
viennent voilà et puis alors sur la
question de de de RTE alors vous avez
tout à fait raison monsieur président il
y a il y a bien eu des scénarios qui ont
été établis par RTE ils sont très très
vastes avec on balaye ils sont balayé
très vaste de un toute toute énergie
renouvelable jusqu'à un certain nombre
de réacteurs nouveaux he assez large et
puis il y a des hypothèses à chaque fois
qui ont été prises avec une part
d'efficacité énergétique une part
d'énergie renouvelable et cetera et et
vous avez cité le bon mot c'est
planification dira que c'est ces
scénarios qui sont son à la base d'un
choix de politique énergétique qui qui
doit être fait doivent immédiatement se
traduire par un exercice robuste de
planification en fonction du scénario
qui sera choisi si ces scénarios
reposent sur une part non
négligeable d'ENR ou de d'efficacité ben
il faut il faut suivre la réalisation
parce que sinon c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure à la fin à la fin des fin
on aura fait des projections mais on n'y
sera pas et et et il on se posera la
question par rapport à au besoins de
d'électricité et et c'est là qu'il faut
il faut éviter cette situation une
question en souriant par rapport à ça
pour pourquoi le gouvernement tarde à
sortir ou à à mettre à la discussion une
PPE qui justement est le point de moi je
suis une autorité indépendante non je
sais c'est pour ça que je dis un souri
je savais que que vous ne pourriez pas
répondre mais bon voilà on est en
commission d'enquête je me permets quand
même de faire la remarque je pense qu'
elle est pas noodine la
remarque merci pour votre réponse
monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Président pardon monsieur bar Président
je peux peut-être répondre sur la
question qui a été posée par Monsieur le
le sénateur sur les compétences
bon allez-y rapidement et je je laisse
le monsieur le rapporteur conclure
d'accordy donc sur les compétences en en
deux mots vous avez raison c'est un
enjeu c'est un enjeu essentiel suite au
à la réorientation nouveau point de
consigne dont je parlais tout à l'heure
un jeu absolument fondamental c'est pour
ça qu'on s'est doté de cet outil pour
mesurer les choses euh et le faire
régulièrement euh le le rapport match
qu'on a publié l'année dernière a permis
d'établir un plan d'action sur le
développement des compétences on est
d'ailleurs cette semaine en pleine
semaine de promotion je dirais sur les
métiers des les métiers du nucléaire
donc ça fait partie des actions de
promotion des métiers du nucléaire cette
promotion elle va auprès de toutes les
les parties prenantes jusque dans les
dans les écoles auprès des des collèges
des parents des profs euh et cetera des
reconversions enfin et cetera en en lien
avec euh France travail on dit
maintenant euh et avec les les les
organisations de de formation il s'avère
que euh la nouvelle perspective données
euh a déjà des effets sur l'attractivité
dans les dans les formations euh
nucléarisées on parle là beaucoup de
métiers finalement assez standard pour
l'industrie avec un un module je dirais
de comment ce qu'on appelle de
coloration au nucléaire euh et il reste
un enjeu de remplissage des classes de
remplissage des formations mais ça
progresse la dynamique est quand même
est quand même constaté après pour ce
qui est des recrutements euh on parle
d'une filière de l'ordre de 200000
personnes donc assez naturellement on
doit à peu près recruter 5000 personnes
par an pour ne serait-ce que se
renouveler parce que en gros on
travaille 40 ans donc do je do pas être
très loin donc quand on parle de de de
l'ordre de 10000 personnes par an ça
veut dire qu'il faut recruter deux fois
plus vite que le renouvellement naturel
je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure euh les
recrutements euh ont déjà commencé on
voit aussi cette dynamique
essentiellement chez les grands acteurs
euh je sais par exemple que framatum
s'est exprimé publiquement sur le fait
que il a il a recruté beaucoup l'année
dernière un peu plus que ce qu'il avait
prévu d'ailleurs ce qui montre que le il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de candidatures
euh l'enjeu qui vient derrière il
concerne les entreprises plus petites
qui euh préparent leur plan
d'investissement leur plan de
recrutement mais qui pourront commencer
à le faire quand elles auront
elles-mêmes plus de visibilité la
croissance je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
est largement portée par par le projet
par les projets neufs Étienne dutille
l'a déjà dit l'activité déjà très élevée
depuis quelques années sur le parc en
exploitation donc mais pour la
croissance qui est portée plutôt par les
par les projets neufs les les
entreprises fournisseurs qui ont
vocation à être
fournisseur prépar des plans de de
recrutement et d'action certaines
commencent à passer partiellement à
l'action mais évidemment c'est une
question de risque ensuite par
l'entrepreneur et et et c'est en train
de de se matérialiser ça qu'on va qu'on
va mesurer avec me semble-t-il mais là
c'est une perception peut-être plus
personnelle du du fait de de la relation
avec tous ces ces patrons d'entreprise
que je représente et que je côtoie une
un enjeu d'attractivité différencié au
sein de la filière c'est que c'est plus
facile de recôter quand on est EDF ou
fromatome que quand on est un forgeron
enfin fond de la Loire pour dire les
choses euh simplement et donc on a
travaillé aussi sur cette sur cette
différenciation il s'avère que le
forgerou en fin fond de la Loire
travaillant 20 % pour le nucléaire quand
il recrute en fait il développe son
entreprise de manière plus large que
simplement pour le nucléaire et si je
cite cet exemple là c'est pour attirer
l'attention des des représentants je
dirais des des Collectiv des des
territoires exactement sur le fait que
cet
accompagnement concerne beaucoup
beaucoup de territoires dans le dans le
pays merci euh merci à vous tous on en
reste là merci beaucoup pour votre
contribution
importante